Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Was für eine bescheuerte Idee ist eigentlich in diesem Kalender dieses Licht im Hintergrund?
Warum? Jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, ich meine, Optik schön und gut.
Und man hat davon abgesehen, schön sieht es ja auch nicht aus, aber die wollten einen coolen Effekt machen.
Wäre es nicht einfach deutlich sinnvoller, einfach nur das hier zu highlighten, wo man gerade drauf ist,
anstatt diesen komischen Spotlight-Effekt da zu machen? Der verwirrt mich.
Naja.
Ah, Leute. Was ist es jetzt geworden? Der in Würzburg, ne, kann ich gleich was zu sagen?
Jetzt warte ich aber noch ein bisschen, weil das fragen sonst wieder 350 Leute den Stream über,
weil wir jetzt ein paar on sind. Ansonsten gibt es eigentlich nichts spannendes Neues.
Ist geil, jetzt habe ich den Stream angemacht, jetzt fängt mir die Nass an zu laufen.
Das gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Als hätte ich jetzt nur darauf gewartet, bis ich den Stream anmache.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen? Ach ja, ich brauche immer noch ein neues iPhone.
Das gucken wir, lass uns das gerade mal schnell gucken. Was kostet es aktuell?
Store, Apple.de. Gibt es da überhaupt welche zu kaufen aktuell?
Also ich wollte mir ja so eins hier kaufen. Ein 14 Plus.
Moment, ist das das Richtige? Ist es billiger geworden?
Ist es billiger geworden?
Hat es nicht 1500 letztens noch gekostet oder habe ich mich verguckt?
Ach nee, einen Pro will ich haben. Einen Pro will ich haben, aber keinen Pro Max, einen Pro.
Ich will das mit 120 Hertz Display.
Das, das, das will ich.
Das hat, ja genau.
Das hat irgendwie 1300 gekostet.
Nee, nee, Pro Max will ich nicht. Das ist mir zu groß. Ich will das.
Gibt es das aktuell lieferbar?
Ja, das reicht, Digge.
Sieht man da irgendwo, ob das lieferbar ist?
Ach hier, Lieferung.
Befünfter bis 13. Januar, Kekkel, Alter. Gibt es bei Amazon noch was?
Ja, a temporary out of stock.
128 bei dem Preis. Wieso 128? Reicht doch.
Die machen unendlich viel Geld mit einfach nur mehr Speicher.
Guck mal, guck mal. Alter, die wollen einfach 400 Euro mehr. Guckt euch das mal an.
400 Euro mehr für ein bisschen mehr Speicher. Nein, ein bisschen mehr Speicher.
Viermal mehr Speicher ist ja doch egal. Der Speicher kostet nichts.
Aber es ist alles temporary out of stock.
Ja, dann wird es dieses Jahr mit dem iPhone wahrscheinlich nichts mehr.
Ja, die wissen echt, wie es geht.
Also eins muss man sagen, so upselling oder wie das heißt, hat Apple wirklich perfektioniert.
Wenn du da über die Webseite gehst, endest zwangsläufig meistens beim aktuellen iPhone-Modell und dann einem der besseren noch.
Weil du dir immer denkst, ey, das eine Upgrade können wir noch machen.
Das kostet nur 100 Euro mehr und dann bist du irgendwann bei 1300 Euro für dein fucking Smartphone.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich ein Euro pro Gigabyte, wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
Ich höre nur auf der einen Seite vom Headset nichts.
Früher konnte man das hier muten. Das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr, oder was?
Jetzt geht es. Ist die Lautstärke richtig eingestellt? Irgendwas backt heute rum.
Ja, viel zu leise. Lull. Und gedacht, was ist denn hier los? Jetzt, jetzt, gut.
So, du arbeitest ja noch bei einer Bank, oder stimmt es, dass man im Bankensektor mit IT-Weiterbildung überschüttet wird?
Das kommt darauf an, wo du bist. Also ja, arbeite ich, aber das kommt darauf an, wo du bist.
Also bei uns ist das jetzt eher Verhalten, oder was es da gibt.
Ich bin gerade noch auf dem alten Rechner, ist richtig. Ich habe gestern die Speed Quiet Grafikkartenkabel.
Wie heißt das Ding nochmal? 12 Volt HWR oder so?
12 Volt HWR Kabel gekriegt per Post. Als Tipp, by the way Leute, wenn ihr euch fragt, wo kann man das bestellen,
nicht hier irgendwo im Internet, einfach bei Be Quiet selber.
Be Quiet hat nämlich einen Ersatzteilstore. Ihr habt einen Ersatzteilstore. Das findet halt niemand.
Da wählt man dann hier aus Netzteil, Dark Power, Produktname.
Da kann man es einfach hier drüber bestellen, weil ansonsten war dieser Kram nirgendwo lieferbar.
Und hier habe ich festgestellt, ach ja, guck mal da, easy. Ach guck mal, ich habe noch eins bekommen.
Ich habe noch eins bekommen. Es kamen gestern oder vorgestern ein paar Posts.
Lustig. Das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr. Interessant. Aber anscheinend, anscheinend wollen das noch mehr haben.
Ja, aber zumindest wenn man Ersatzteile braucht, ist es wirklich am besten. Man guckt bei denen.
Geht schnell, innerhalb von ein paar Tagen ist es jetzt angekommen. Und die haben das meistens auch lieferbar.
Ich bin ganz im Ernst, solange es geht, solange es noch neue Updates gibt, gibt es ja eigentlich keinen Grund.
Ich würde mein iPhone 11 auch noch behalten, wenn ich es noch weiter benutzen könnte.
Aber ich kann mein iPhone 11 ja wahrscheinlich ab April nicht mehr verwenden.
Weil es ja nicht mein iPhone 11 ist, sondern das von der Firma, wo ich gerade arbeite.
Und ab 31.3. arbeite ich da ja wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Ich sage jetzt nur wahrscheinlich, also 99% nicht mehr, ich sage jetzt nur wahrscheinlich, weil ich die Kündigung noch nicht abgegeben habe.
Aber es kann eigentlich so gut wie nichts mehr dazwischen kommen.
Ja, das lohnt sich. Also du musst mal gucken, wie viel länger das wirklich läuft.
Weil es kostet halt generell also Smartphone Preise und Grafikkarten Preise.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, Chet, was würdet ihr lieber kaufen?
Na, aktuell ist es die Kündigung.
Ja, das ist die Kündigung.
Das ist die Kündigung.
Was würdet ihr lieber kaufen?
Eine aktuelle Grafikkarte oder ein aktuelles Smartphone?
Ein aktuelles iPhone muss man iPhone 1 haben gibt es ja deutlich günstiger.
Ein aktuelles Highend iPhone oder Grafikkarte?
Im Prinzip nimmt sich das Preiß ja gar nicht mehr so viel, nur das Grafikkarten tatsächlich noch ein Dicken teurer sind.
gpu ja gpu habe ich jetzt ja schon also wirds neues iphone aber trotzdem das soll sich
schon unglaublich teuer
people please musik ja ja ich werde dazu was erzählen ich sage auch gleich noch was zu
bevor das jetzt wieder 350 mal im stream gefragt wird aber wir gucken uns mal gerade
die aktuellen github trends an das gucken wir uns immer ich google trends mann das gucken
wir uns immer einmal sonntags an mal gucken was es da so gibt moment moment hatte ich
nicht sogar schon offen doch hier ne also was trendet denn diese woche was sonst das
ist ja gerade überall total angesagt ein python compiler gibt es ja schon ein paar
es noch einer was macht er noch besser als der rest es gibt auch wieder irgendwelche
probleme mit packages oder sowas garantiert uptime kuma ja nice endlich mal was was ich
kenne was in den github trends ist habe ich zwar nicht mal bei mir im einsatz war aber
trotzdem sehr nice
ich will mal in ruhe angucken was es da neues gibt ja jetzt haben wir sonst noch chat gpt
chat gpt ai alibaba was auch immer no description und der rest ist auf china chinesen sprache
alles klar jetzt wissen wir bescheid irgendjemand ahnung was das macht ich sehe c++ das schreckt
mich schon mal ab
es ist ein search engine alles klar blazingly fast written in rust
das weltkit ist erschienen in 1.0 das habe ich gelesen ja das motor endlich mal was das
hat es verdient das gibt es schon so lang es war bestimmt auch zum nicht zum ersten
mal in den trends mit einiges bei mir heim automatisierungstechnisch nicht funktionieren
ohne das motor nice zu projekt du hast ein werbespot für die us marines bekommen vielleicht entspricht
es ja sonst einem view verhalten vielleicht guckst du ja gern military content oh ja neuer
monitor das steht bei mir auch demnächst an
ich vermute mal es wird aber noch ein paar monate dauern es sind jetzt ein paar monitor
angekündigt oder ich kann mir immer nicht nicht nicht entscheiden ob ich oder sagen
soll oder oled leute oled versus oled moment das muss nur kurze umfrage machen ich mach
mal was sagt ihr ich bin gespannt
du kriegst hauptsächlich englische werbung das liegt bestimmt auch ein bisschen daran
wie dein browser eingestellt ist oder ob du über den vpn oder so zugreifst aber wahrscheinlich
greifst du nicht über den vpn so
wie
Bisschen an wie so ein Backstein, weißt auch nicht. OLED.
Niemand spricht den Kram doch so aus.
Brauchst du irgendwas kurzes griffiges? Ja, ich tendiere auch zu OLED anstatt zu OOOH LED.
Oder O, OLED.
Jetzt alles Blödsinn. Ich kaufe in den OLED-Monitor
1440p 27 Zoll, wenn es dann mal ordentlich welche gibt.
Aktuell gibt es ja einen angekündigt von LG für ungefähr 1000 Euro. Es muss natürlich auch alles immer super teuer sein.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass nächstes Jahr, also 2023, einige kommen. Guck mal hier, OLED.
Von LG.
Das Ding.
Ja, also das Ding finde ich tatsächlich sehr spannend.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der Unterschied ist zwischen OLED und Mini-LED.
CRT, ja 27 Zoll CRT, 16, 16 zu 9 wird es halt schwierig.
Und am besten auch noch mit Displayport-Anschluss.
Sowas müsste mal einer bauen, Alter, dann bricht dein Schreibtrecht runter zusammen.
Ich will halt, es gibt es gibt teilweise schon Monitore mit irgendwie 45 Zoll, aber ganz ehrlich will kein 45 Zoll Monitor 27 Zoll und dafür zwei Stück.
Das ist gut. Allerdings muss der zweite dann auch nicht so ein teurer Gaming-Monitor sein.
Aber die Kombination aus 240 Hertz plus OLED-Technologie, also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, dann hat sich mit Input-Lag und sonstigen Sachen tatsächlich erledigt.
Aktuell habe ich einen 240 Hertz, ganz normal, LED, TFT, LED, LCD, wie auch immer.
Nein, die Hintergrundbeleuchtung sind LEDs, aber es ist nach wie vor ein TFT, LCD, ach, keine Ahnung, zumindest der ist schon ziemlich gut.
Was Input-Lag angeht, die 360 Hertz habe ich nicht mitgemacht, werde ich auch nicht machen, als nächstes wird es wahrscheinlich sowas werden hier bei mir.
Mal gucken, wann es das denn dann wirklich lieferbar gibt. Reorder kann es nämlich aktuell nur.
Das Einbrennen, na, ich würde jetzt mal erwarten, dass man die Monitore normal benutzbar macht, ja, also.
Mal gucken, was wir mal machen, also, ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen zu viel, aber ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen zu viel, ja.
Also, ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen zu viel, aber ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen zu viel, ja.
Das Einbrennen, na, ich würde jetzt mal erwarten, dass man die Monitore normal benutzbar macht, ja, also.
Mal gucken, müssen wir mal erste Tests abwarten, deswegen werde ich hier auch definitiv nichts pre-ordern, irgendwie so ein Blödsinn, das wird gekauft frühestens, wenn es dazu ein paar Tests gibt.
Und ich werde mir wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht den hier kaufen, sondern abwarten, weil nächstes Jahr über kommen jede Menge solcher Monitore.
Äh, tippe ich zumindest drauf, ja.
Ja. Mehr als 175 Hertz bringen noch, ja, das kann schon sein, hängt allerdings auch von der Technik ab, ja, OLED ist an sich eh schon mal ein bisschen noch mehr responsive.
Aber, wie gesagt, ich als Boomer mit 150 Millisekunden Reaktionszeit, was ja schon im Pro-Gamer-Bereich liegt,
ist das natürlich wichtig, dass ich auch einen Monitor habe, der dazu passt. Ich mein, besser treffen werde ich trotzdem nichts.
Es war jetzt nur so Halbkapper, ich habe wirklich für mein Alter ziemlich schnelle Reaktionszeit, aber ich mache ja auch nichts anderes als vom Rechnersitz, wenn ich nicht schnelle Reaktionszeit habe, wer sonst?
Treffen tue ich trotzdem nichts.
Weil letztens wieder über Battlefield gesehen hat. Ja, also 360 Hertz fand ich jetzt auch, hat mich auch bis jetzt die Geräte nicht überzeugt, aber 240 Hertz OLED ist glaube ich das, da ist wirklich so das Limit, wo ich sage, hey, also ich glaube mehr brauchst du dann echt nicht, wobei mal abwarten in ein paar Jahren.
Wir haben letztens in Reaktionszeit einen Test gemacht, ich hatte zwischen so 100, 155 und 170 Millisekunden Reaktionszeit.
Das ging richtig, richtig ab, haben sie alle geglaubt, haben sie mir erstmal gar nicht geglaubt, als ich das gesagt habe hier im Stream.
Dann haben wir live den Test gemacht im Stream. Easy.
Mit der Zeit verschiebt sich das Bild. Echt, warum soll sich das Bild verschieben?
Was, bei einem OLED? Warum? Einbrennen verstehe ich ja noch, aber verschieben? Warum soll sich das Bild verschieben?
Verstehe ich nicht. Nun gut.
Nachdem jetzt einige da sind, also um der Frage, die trotzdem wahrscheinlich 350 mal kommen wird im Stream,
würde ich mir relativ sicher, aber um der Frage jetzt mal soweit vorzubeugen, zumindest für alle, die schon da sind.
Moin, unifying 1337. Also, ich habe jetzt einen neuen Job angenommen, ich werde kündigen, da wo ich arbeite.
Ich habe noch nicht abgegeben, weil ich den finalen Arbeitsvertrag noch nicht in Papierform hier habe und noch nicht in Papierform hier habe.
Ich habe das aber alles schon verbindlich und per E-Mail vertragstechnisch.
Ich warte jetzt noch drauf, bis das Ding endlich per Post kommt und sobald das unterschrieben ist, werde ich dann meine Kündigung einreichen.
Die anderen Angebote habe ich schon abgesagt, was echt etwas, also was mir wirklich schwer gefallen ist,
weil ich hatte ja vorher schon mit einem Anbieter, also mit einem IT-Dienstleister aus Würzburg was ausgemacht
und mit denen war ich eigentlich auch schon soweit fertig und mir soweit einig, dass ich bei denen sogar schon den Vertrag in der Post hatte
und jetzt musste ich denen das halt absagen. Ich wusste echt gar nicht, wie ich das gescheit machen soll.
Das war mir übelst peinlich da anzurufen und zu sagen, Jungs, wird doch nichts.
Aber letztendlich irgendwo habe ich mir gedacht, ist es ja trotzdem Business, was willst du machen, ja.
Also habe ich das abgesagt und ich gehe jetzt von einer Bank in Frankfurt zur anderen Bank.
Also habe ich das abgesagt und ich gehe jetzt von einer Bank in Frankfurt zur anderen Bank in Frankfurt.
Die ist ungefähr 200 Meter nicht, aber keine Ahnung, die sind irgendwie 500 Meter voneinander entfernt.
Also es ist ungefähr 500 Meter Luftlinie voneinander weg alles, wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Was ist das, wo ich dann arbeite?
Boomerang ist das, wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Aber wenigstens mehr Geld und 99% Remote, also es ist...
Lass mal überlegen, wie viel ist denn das Remote?
Also man muss alle 14 Tage mal einen Tag hin, ich weiß nicht, wie viel Remote das ist.
Also quasi einen Tag auf acht Arbeitstage bei mir.
Einmal die Woche bis 14 Tage, irgendwie sowas.
Aber selbst einmal die Woche, habe ich auch gesagt, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Weil es ist ja in Frankfurt, es ist quasi um die Ecke, da komme ich ganz gut hin.
Einmal die Woche ist okay.
Zumal die im Vergleich zu meinem aktuellen Job und vor allem dann auch nochmal zu dem anderen Job, den ich in Würzburg schon angenommen habe, echt ordentlich bezahlen.
Also das andere in Würzburg war schon nicht verkehrt.
Letztendlich ist es unter dem Strich, was ich aktuell verdiene, auch nicht verkehrt, wenn man das mal vergleicht, mit was man so im Durchschnitt bekommt in Deutschland.
Aber letztendlich, man muss ja auch mal gucken, wo man unterwegs ist, Frankfurter Bankensektor, da ist einfach ordentlich Kohle drin.
Und jetzt bist du bei 100%, jetzt bin ich tatsächlich sechsstellig bei den neuen, ja.
War ich vorher nicht.
Aber jetzt bin ich allerdings auch jetzt nicht irgendwie im hohen sechsstelligen Bereich oder so, das ist logisch.
Also ich verdiene da jetzt keine 400.000 Euro.
Aber sechsstellig ist es jetzt, ja.
Niedrig, niedrig sechsstellig.
Also es ist sechsstellig, hat aber noch eine Eins an der ersten Stelle.
Also niedrig sechsstellig.
Also es ist sechsstellig, hat aber noch eine Eins an der ersten Stelle. Also niedrig sechsstellig.
Nein, Linux Engineer bin ich jetzt.
Aber Senior, Senior, Linux Engineer.
Was sind deine neuen Aufgaben im Job oder bleibt es gleich?
Na also 100% ich erzählen kann ich euch das nicht.
Weil ich selbst noch nicht weiß, also ich weiß, was die mir erzählt haben und ich weiß, was in der Stellenanzeige stand.
Also.
So wirklich wissen, tue ich das ja erst.
Wenn ich, wenn ich da angefangen habe. Also ich kanns euch, ich kanns euch so ungefähr erzählen. Also es ist tatsächlich von, von den Skills ja relativ ähnlich zu dem, was ich jetzt mach.
Wenn ich weiß, was ich jetzt mach, kann ich mein Video dazu angucken.
Es ist wohl ein großer Teil klassisch noch Systemadministration.
Es ist Infrastructure as Code.
Mit Ansible und Puppet. Es ist bisschen Cloud Provisioning mit Terraform.
Ein paar, keine Ahnung, Kompanete, Manifest, Yammeres erstellen.
Ich weiß es noch nicht genau, mal gucken, was da auf einen zukommt. Ich kanns schlecht, schlecht einschätzen jetzt, weil zwischen den beiden, die ich jetzt ausgebildet habe,
ich weiß es noch nicht genau, mal gucken, was da auf einen zukommt. Ich kanns schlecht, schlecht einschätzen jetzt, weil zwischen den Technologien, die aufgelistet werden und das, was man dann wirklich macht,
das kann man, kann man schlecht sagen. Dann muss ich mal abwarten, bis es losgeht.
Also Anfang kann ich eh erst im April.
Also es dauert noch ein bisschen. Ich habe ja noch Kündigungs, drei Monate Kündigungsfrist.
Du hast als Schüler null Income. Ja, aber du hast danach bestimmt auch mal mehr als null.
Als null.
Wie viele Stunden? Ja, aber vier Tage.
Vier Tage, 80%.
Pog.
Bist du auf GitHub in der agilen Progas Gruppe?
Das ist bestimmt toll, wenn man das in die Bewerbung schreibt.
GitHub. Oh, nicht in der agilen Progas Gruppe.
Okay, ich erzähl euch das mal kurz, wie das Ganze gelaufen ist. Ich erzähl euch das mal.
Also ich war weder Probearbeiten dort, noch habe ich irgendwie sonderlich viel im Vorfeld mir da angekündigt. Also folgendermaßen.
Ich war in Würzburg.
Also ich nenne mich immer IT-Dienstleister in Würzburg. Was zum Teufel soll denn das sein?
Also ich war beim IT-Dienstleister in Würzburg.
Hab vorher mit denen einen Remote-Termin gemacht, dann habe ich einen Termin vor Ort gemacht mit den Teammitgliedern. Wir haben uns super verstanden.
Geld war in Ordnung, Arbeitsbedingungen, Homeoffice war alles gut. Hab ich gesagt, gut, können wir machen.
Und da haben sie mir einen Vertrag geschickt. So.
Dann hatte ich den Vertrag, bzw. ich hatte den Vertrag erstmal nur per E-Mail und dann kam er ein paar Tage später per Post.
So. Und in der Zwischenzeit, wo ich schon den Vertrag per E-Mail hatte, aber der Vertrag noch nicht per Post da war, wahrscheinlich hätte ich ihn nämlich sonst unterschrieben,
hat sich ein Ex-Kollege gemeldet, mit dem ich früher bei der Bank gearbeitet habe, wo ich jetzt gerade arbeite.
Und er hat gemeint, Max, ich arbeite gerade für die sowieso sonst was Bank in Frankfurt.
Und wir suchen noch so zwei, drei neue Leute. Wie schaut es denn aus? Hast du Bock?
Und ich sagte, ja klar, passt ja wunderbar, habe ich Bock drauf.
Dann habe ich mit ihm telefoniert und ich habe ihm mal meinen Lebenslauf und meine Skill-Liste geschickt.
Die Skill-Liste haben wir uns hier im Stream auch schon angeguckt und die hat er seinem Chef weitergeschickt.
Und da war ich gerade im Bauhaus und habe einen Weihnachtsbaum gekauft.
Da klingelt auf einmal mein Handy, so, keine Ahnung, eineinhalb Stunden später.
Es gibt auch nur eine Handvoll Leute, mit denen ich mich gut verstehe und da hat der Ex-Kollege dazugehört.
So, und da habe ich irgendwie eineinhalb Stunden später, hat mich dann, während ich im Bauhaus war und Weihnachtsbaum gekauft habe,
der Chef von meinem Ex-Kollege angerufen, hat gefragt, hier, wie sieht es denn aus?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was er gesagt hat.
Genau, genau, er hat gesagt, ich soll ihm noch mal offiziell die Bewerbung schicken.
Weil es ist eine Bank und da müssen natürlich Bewerbungsprozesse und alles eingehalten werden und sonst was.
Dann habe ich dann ihm noch mal offiziell die Bewerbung geschickt.
Das musste man über so ein Portal machen, wo man dann auch zustimmt, dass datenschutztechnisch die Bewerbung verarbeitet werden darf.
Und hast du nicht gesehen, wir haben ja mittlerweile so krasse Auflagen in Deutschland.
Kannst dich einfach mal Bewerbung per PDF hier irgendwo hinschicken.
So, dann habe ich dort die Bewerbung hochgeladen.
Im Endeffekt war es mein Lebenslauf und die Skillliste.
Das war sehr wenig, hat dann auch der von der Personalabteilung gesagt,
ein bisschen mehr könnte ich schon noch hochladen, vielleicht noch ein paar Zeugnisse oder so, anstatt es einfach nur zwei Dokumente.
So, dann habe ich das da hochgeladen und irgendwie zwei Tage später haben die sich schon gemeldet und haben gesagt,
hier, Max, hast du nächste Woche Zeit?
Oh, ja, klar, passt.
So, dann bin ich nächste Woche nach Frankfurt gefahren und habe da mich mit einem von der Personalabteilung
und dem Teamleiter von dieser IT-Abteilung oder diesem Team, wo ich dann hingehe,
bzw. das Team, was die Stelle ausgeschrieben hat, hatten wir, pass mal auf, haltet euch fest,
fast drei Stunden Vorstellungsgespräch, fast drei Stunden, also 2 Stunden 42 oder so was.
Das hat ein bisschen geschlaucht, aber es war insofern wichtig, weil ich musste ja mitkriegen, was da so läuft,
und die mussten von mir was mitkriegen und das Ganze musste möglichst schnell gehen,
weil ich muss, wie gesagt, ich muss gekündigt haben, spätestens, aber allerspätestens hier bis 30.
Das heißt, wenn wir hier, wir haben letzte Woche, also wir haben diese nicht letzte,
wir haben diese Woche ja hier erst Vorstellungsgespräch gemacht und bis hierhin muss ich quasi Vertrag haben,
unterschreiben und dass ich bis hier maximal kündigen kann, also es ist etwas sehr, sehr knappes.
Ich habe jetzt alles hochgeladen dort, ich habe wirklich, ich habe wirklich alles hochgeladen,
weil ich habe, ich habe hochgeladen mein Schulzeugnis, meine IHK Abschlussding,
von meinem ersten Aushilfsjob das Zeugnis, vom Provider das Zeugnis,
von meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber das Zwischenzeugnis, vom Zivildienst die Bestätigung,
ich habe wirklich alles hochgeladen, was es gibt.
Also jetzt können Sie sich nicht beschweren, dass Sie zu wenig, zu wenig irgendwie Infos über mich haben.
So zumindest habe ich jetzt dann direkt am Tag danach ein Angebot gekriegt, verbindlich schon,
jetzt Vertrag per Mail und jetzt warte ich auf Vertrag, Vertrag per, also noch zusätzlich auf den Vertrag per Post,
so dass ich dann nächstes Jahr dort anfangen kann und wisst ihr was das Beste ist?
Das habe ich euch ja noch gar nicht erzählt.
Wobei, ich habe das, ich habe das glaube ich schon vor ein paar Wochen mal erzählt.
Habe ich euch vor ein paar Wochen erzählt, dass ich mich zusammen mit einem aktuellen,
also mit einem aktuellen Arbeitskollege, mit dem ich dort wo ich jetzt gerade arbeite öfters zusammen arbeite,
habe ich euch da erzählt, dass wir uns zusammen beworben haben bei einem Laden?
Ich glaube schon, ich glaube das habe ich euch erzählt.
Wir haben uns so doppelt beworben und es kann sein, dass ich das erwähnt habe.
Zumindest als ich dort war, habe ich erfahren, die suchen noch jemand für diese Stelle,
halt für eine andere Stelle, die exakt mehr oder weniger den gleichen Wortlaut hat.
Und ich hatte passenderweise schon den Lebenslauf von meinem aktuellen Arbeitskollege dabei
und habe gesagt, also wenn ihr noch Leute sucht, ich kenne da jemand.
Habe ich den Lebenslauf rausgepackt, habe ihn in die Hand gedrückt und einen Tag später
haben die sich bei meinem Arbeitskollege gemeldet und haben gefragt, hier wie sieht es denn aus, hast du Bock?
Und jetzt läuft es wahrscheinlich so, dass sowohl er als auch ich da anfangen können am 1. April.
Was? Glück gehabt oder?
Dann kenne ich meinen Exkollege dort plus meinen aktuellen Kollege Wechsel mit,
also kenne ich wenigstens schon ein paar Leute, das finde ich immer gut.
Drei Monate Kündigungsfrist sagt, es ist ja noch schlimmer bei mir,
es ist ja nicht drei Monate Kündigungsfrist, es ist drei Monate Kündigungsfrist zum Quartal.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt nicht bis Ende des Monats kündige, dann kann ich erst wieder in drei Monaten
plus drei Monate kündigen, also dann erst im Juni oder so.
Noch Anwerberbonus rausgannelt, das ist ein gutes Stichwort, ja, könnte ich wahrscheinlich probieren, ist mir aber egal.
Also für mich habe ich das ausgefüllt, dass mein Exkollege Werbenmitarbeiterbonus bekommt.
Ich ist angegeben, ja, ohne Scheiß, wenn man Leute kennt, ist es einfach besser.
Es hat Vorteile, es hat ehrlich gesagt mehrere Vorteile, wenn man irgendwo hinwechselt, wo man jemanden kennt.
Also erstens kennt man selbst schon jemand und zweitens macht es natürlich auch immer einen besseren Eindruck,
also macht es immer einen besseren, einen guten Eindruck, wenn man empfohlen wird und wenn die Leute einen quasi in das eigene Team holen,
heißt das irgendwie auch, man passt wohl ganz gut dazu.
Also ich glaube, das ist für alle Seiten von Vorteil, wenn man auf Empfehlungen von jemanden,
den man kennt bzw. mit dem man sich gut verstanden hat, irgendwo hingeht.
Also zumindest stehen dann die Chancen deutlich besser, dass das alles passt.
Wer hat einen aktuellen Job jetzt frei? Also soweit ich gehört habe, ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen...
kurz ein bisschen Klimaanlage anmachen. Also nicht kühlen, wärmen. Jetzt nehme ich gerade nur 19 Grad oder so ein bisschen kühl.
Nee, nee, noch kälter. Was haben wir denn? Warte mal, ich wollte mal kurz bei mir auf meine Temperatur gucken. Was haben wir denn?
18,6, ja, ein bisschen wärmer kann es schon noch sein.
Also, wird ein aktueller Job jetzt frei? Naja, offiziell erst einmal ab April, aber ich habe schon gehört, dass jemand anderes dort, wo ich gerade arbeite,
seine Stelle abgebaut werden soll und der dann meinen Spot übernehmen könnte.
Wäre ja eigentlich auch ganz gut, dann haben die dort weniger Lücken und Projekte.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt ja nicht vor, da meinen aktuellen Kollegen irgendwie mehr Stress als nötig zu verursachen.
Was mich überhaupt nicht mehr interessiert, ist dann quasi die Firma, wo ich jetzt aktuell arbeite, weil das hat schon seinen Grund, warum ich wechsle.
Ich werde das drei Monate noch ordentlich übergeben, alles, und dann, weil mich vom Acker...
CU, sage ich dann, CU. Wie lange meine Kündigungsfrist war? Drei Monate zum Quartalsende, korrekt.
Also, ich kann auch, wenn ich das dann, wenn dann alles in trockenen Tüchern ist, mache ich vielleicht noch ein Video über das Vorstellungsgespräch.
Ich will jetzt erst mal abwarten, ob das, ob das alles gut ist.
Weil es hat ja keinen Sinn, wenn ich sage, neuer Job, und es klappt irgendwie doch nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe schon ein verbindliches Angebot, eigentlich kann jetzt da nichts mehr dazwischen kommen.
Aber letztendlich weiß ich das ja erst, wenn ich wirklich hier da liegen habe.
Zumindest, wenn ich das jetzt mal abwarten kann.
Aber letztendlich weiß ich das ja erst, wenn ich wirklich hier da liegen habe. Zumindest, ein paar Fragen waren tatsächlich sehr trickreich.
Zum Beispiel wurde, Leute, ich kann euch, ihr werdet euch wegkecken, ich sage es euch.
Ihr werdet euch absolut wegkecken bei dem, was ich jetzt erzähle. Und zwar, ich wurde im Vorstellungsgespräch gefragt, also Herr Max, was müssten wir, das waren so trickreiche Personalerfragen halt.
Muss man sagen, also der hat schon, der hat es schon gut gemacht, der hat es schon gut gemacht.
Also der Personaler hat seinen Job wirklich, versteht seinen Job wirklich, muss man sagen.
Zumindest, er hat mich gefragt, also Herr Max, was müssten wir denn hier wirklich machen, um sie so richtig auf die Palme zu bringen?
Wahrscheinlich wollte er testen, ob ich mich gerne streite oder sowas.
Das ist so eine typische, richtig trickreiche Frage.
Also was müssten wir hier dann machen, um sie so richtig auf die Palme zu bringen?
Wisst ihr, was ich geantwortet habe? Ich habe gesagt, Windows administrieren.
Und die Antwort, die Antwort hat er sich aber, hat er aber nicht gelten lassen.
Die Antwort hat er aber nicht gelten lassen.
Hat gemeint, ja mal jetzt von so technischen Sachen weg, er meint ja eher so organisatorisch und alles drumherum.
Aber ich habe gesagt, hey, ich habe von Windows keine Ahnung, ja.
Es steht auch nirgendswo, irgendwo in meinen Skills oder im Lebenslauf, sonstwo, nicht mal ansatzweise irgendwas von Windows.
Ich habe dann gesagt, lass mal überlegen, was habe ich denn als Antwort dann noch gegeben?
Achso, ja, tatsächlich, ich habe was gesagt, was mich wirklich nervt, wenn man rückwirkend Sachen umdefiniert, um dann irgendwelche Leuten den Schwarzen Peter in die Schuhe schieben zu können.
Also zum Beispiel eine Sache, die beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber passiert ist, habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt.
Es wurde zum Beispiel gesagt, hey, wenn wir Service XYZ in die Cloud umziehen, dann ist uns bewusst, dass es in einer Übergangsphase da zu Problemen kommen kann.
Das wurde ja auch darauf hingewiesen im Vorfeld.
Und dann wurde von ganz oberer Stelle gesagt, nein, dieser Umzug soll exakt so passieren und so schnell wie möglich und auch so wie es angesagt war, trotz der Bedenken.
Und sollte es zu Problemen kommen, also Leute, ohne Scheiß, diese Aussage wurde eins zu eins so getroffen und sollte es zu Problemen durch den Cloud umzukommen an dieser Stelle, dann nehmen wir die in Kauf.
So, und dann könnt ihr euch vorstellen, es kam zu Problemen, unter anderem durch den Cloud Umzug, weil manche Sachen nicht bedacht wurden, kann ich jetzt dem Detail nicht so sehr erzählen.
Und danach wurde gesagt, wie kann das sein, dass der Service Down war?
Und dann wurde das quasi retroaktiv umbenannt, nicht umbenannt, umdefiniert, was denn mit Problemen beim Umzug gemeint war.
Um dann sagen zu können, die Leute, die den Umzug exakt so gemacht haben, wie es damals trotz angemeldeter Bedenken gefordert war, sollen jetzt daran schuld sein, dass es nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Und das sind so Sachen, die mich tatsächlich aufregt.
Das habe ich natürlich ein bisschen schöner umschrieben, da erzählt und das war wahrscheinlich auch okay, die Antwort war, da hat keiner mal was drauf gesagt.
Wie läuft es mit deinen Bewerbungen?
Habe ich gerade was zu erzählt.
Also ich habe jetzt einen neuen Job angenommen in Frankfurt, bei einer anderen Bank.
Ja, fast schon.
Geht in die Richtung.
Ich wechsle quasi von einer Bank in Frankfurt zu einer anderen Bank, die irgendwie keine Ahnung kann.
800 Meter Luftlinie entfernt ist.
Und das erste, was ich erlebt habe, war der Wahnsinn.
Ich war jetzt ja ein paar Wochen nicht mehr in dieser Ecke in Frankfurt, weil was soll ich da, wenn ich Urlaub habe.
Ich bin am Hauptbahnhof ausgestiegen, bin durch die Nebenstraße gelaufen, auf einmal kommt jemand an und meint so zu mir Hallo und ich so Hallo.
Ich laufe so weiter, dann kommt er dann noch einen Schritt auf mich zu und meint so Marihuana, Marihuana.
Nein, nein, kein Marihuana.
Dann bin ich weg.
Dann wollten wir halt erst mal gleich Drogen verkaufen.
Das ist typische Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof-Seitenstraße, Alter.
Der erste Typ, der Hallo sagt, ist gleich irgendein Dealer.
By the way, was ist eigentlich aus Marihuana-Legalisierung geworden, sollte das nicht, weil das würde denen ja komplett die Geschäftsgrundlage entziehen dort.
Ah, zumindest dem.
Ist doch, nee, ist glaube ich noch nicht.
Ist noch nicht.
Vielleicht wollte er auch noch seine Restbestände loswerden.
Das ist auch geil gewesen.
Das erste, irgendein Drogenhändler, was Drogenhändler? Er ist aus irgendeinem Dealer in Frankfurt über den Weg gelaufen.
Naja, so, also was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Was schauen wir, was haben wir denn, was haben wir denn hier, was können wir uns denn angucken?
New Most Popular, oh ja, Data is Beautiful, das guck ich mal gerne, zeig mal her.
Lass, lass, lass, lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz gucken.
Also, da kann ich die Musik laufen lassen.
Oder läuft, oder ist da Musik dabei?
Ja, Most Popular Messenger, ok, 1998, Quartal 2.
Ja, ICQ und natürlich, was sonst, AOL Messenger und MIRC.
Also ich muss, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hab alles davon, also hab ich installiert gehabt, hat kaum jemand verwendet von meinen Bekannten.
Hier ICQ war das Ding schlechthin.
ICQ war hier auch noch vor 1998, also als das mit Modem und so, also ICQ, ICQ, beste, hab ich damals, kennt noch jemand Sumo Volleyball?
ICQ, ICQ Sumo Volleyball.
Genau, kennt noch jemand Sumo Volleyball?
Das war echt so ein Minigame in ICQ eingebaut, Sumo Volleyball.
So, also, MIRC natürlich, damals, damals auch.
Also ich hab hauptsächlich tatsächlich ICQ und MMO, technisch war IRC.
Das hier war quasi so ein bisschen, ich mein, Discord ist ja hauptsächlich auf Voice Chat und sonst was, aber das war für uns damals so ein bisschen das, was die Leute heute in Discord machen, ja.
Absprechen so nach dem Motto, hey, wollen wir heute Abend Gruppe machen oder was weiß ich, heute Abend Raid und solche, solche Geschichten jetzt nicht intern mit ein paar Leuten in der Gilde oder so, sondern teilweise auch komplett übergreifen.
Also da gab's, da gab's dann IRC.
Da gab's dann IRC Channel für MMO Krami.
Ja, IRC gibt's heute immer noch, aber die Benutzung ist glaub ich jetzt auch nicht, auch nicht mehr das.
Also IRC und ICQ war's bei mir hauptsächlich.
Ich hatte AOL Messenger bestimmt installiert, wahrscheinlich Yahoo Messenger auch und MSN natürlich auch, aber verwendet hab ich ehrlich gesagt eigentlich so gut wie nur, so gut wie ausschließlich ICQ und bisschen IRC.
In 98, ja.
Tencent QQ.
Die China-Chinesen sind jetzt auch ins Internet gekommen.
Siehst du mal Leute, muss ich mal vorstellen, die hatten 1999, als bei uns ICQ voll angesagt war und MSN und sowas, hatten die China-Chinesen einen Messenger, der mehr User hatte.
Niemand hat davon gehört.
Es hat damals, ich mein heute ja auch, ja heute kriegst du ja auch kaum was mit, aber immer noch mehr, was bei den Chinesen im Internet so passiert.
Aber damals hast du ja wirklich gar keinen Plan davon gehabt.
Das war noch mehr andere Welt als heute.
Guck mal hier, wie es abgeht.
So, MSN.
Ja, MSN, also ich, das kann ich mich doch dran erinnern, 2000 rum oder so.
Ich hatte auch ab und zu mal MSN.
MSN hatte finde ich, hatte für die damalige Zeit finde ich ganz coole Emotes.
Aber AOL habe ich nie großartig verwendet.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass das so riesengroß damals war.
Also es war trotz, es war bei mir im Endeffekt zwischenzeitlich dann drei Sachen, es war ICQ, MSN und immer noch für MMOs immer noch IRC.
Und das hier war glaube ich so ein Multi-Kline-Messenger, da konntest du dann ICQ, AOL und MSN in einem haben.
Jetzt geht MSN aber ab und die China-Chinesen überholen alles.
Also ich habe ICQ glaub noch verwendet lange bis bis bis 2004 oder so habe ich das glaube ich noch verwendet bis 2005.
Boah, Alter, was zum Teufel geht mit MSN ab?
Wurde das dann mit Windows ausgeliefert bei Windows 2000 oder warum ist das auf einmal so krass abgegangen?
Eye-Chat? Das ist aber nichts von Apple, oder?
Warum ist denn MSN? Das ist bestimmt gebundelt geworden mit Windows.
Ich wüsste nicht, warum das sonst so abgehen sollte.
Ach, der Eye-Chat ist Apple.
Alter, MSN flutscht. Oh nee, oh nee, oh nee.
Ich glaube Skype war der nervigste, also der mieseste von allen, der sich aber dann teilweise fast allein durchgesetzt hat.
Es gab ja mal eine Zeit, da hat quasi jeder Skype verwendet.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, 2007 und 2008 als ich mit YouTube angefangen habe, da ging im Prinzip 90% über Skype.
Guckt euch das mal an, Skype flutscht.
Und jetzt gehen alle China-Chinesen ins Internet.
Google Talk. Ist das nicht auch eines der Sachen, die Google schon längst wieder eingestellt hat nach ein paar Jahren?
Blackberry. Gut, an die erinnert sich heute keiner mehr.
Aber das AOL bis 2006, 2007 noch so weit oben war, war mir gar nicht bewusst gut. Ich habe den ja auch nie verwendet.
Jetzt gibt es zwischenzeitlich... Okay, guck mal, das ist so ein typisches Microsoft-Ding.
Das ist wohl mal kurzzeitig... Ach nee, Moment. MSN wurde umbenannt in Windows Live Messenger.
Okay, deswegen ist der jetzt da oben.
Das ist auch so ein Microsoft-Ding, dass man Skype... Gut, Skype war glaube ich ursprünglich zum größten Teil ja VoIP.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, was das hier macht. Das ist eigentlich so ein Multi-Messenger gewesen.
Aber das ist auch so ein Microsoft-Ding, dass man wieder zwei Sachen hier zeitgleich hatte.
Okay, ICQ ist eigentlich jetzt nahezu... Bedeutungslos kann man nicht sagen, aber auf dem absteigenden Ast.
Auch wenn es noch steigt, aber die anderen steigen stärker.
Blackberry müsste sich demnächst auch schon fast wieder erledigt haben.
Und ich glaube so in dem Dreh habe ich jetzt auch aufgehört...
ICQ zu benutzen.
Stimmt, Microsoft hat Skype gekauft, du hast recht.
Es war ja gar nicht von Anfang an Skype. Äh, nicht von Anfang an Microsoft-Skype.
Aber die China-Chinesen gehen ab hier, guckt's euch an.
Blackberry. Ah, Blackberry! Leute, das kann ich euch sagen, Blackberry hat sich bald erledigt.
Dauert nicht mehr allzu lang, dann ist Blackberry wieder weg vom Fenster.
Okay, AOL sinkt total schnell und ICQ nimmt zu, okay.
Rennen die alten AOL-Benutzer alle jetzt zur ICQ, oder?
Was zum Teufel, warum hat ICQ so viele Benutzer? 2008 war das doch schon komplett auf dem absteigenden Ast, dachte ich.
Also zumindest, ich hab's nicht mehr verwendet.
Also AOL hab ich nicht mitbekommen, weil hab ich nie benutzt.
Die China-Chinesen ziehen halt wieder an alle. Oh je, oh je.
WhatsApp, das flutscht jetzt auch gleich.
Das war die Zeit, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, wo die ganzen Boomer von WhatsApp erfahren haben.
Und wisst ihr, was die gesagt haben? Die haben gesagt, ho, kennst du diese neue App?
WhatsApp, ho, da kannst du kostenlos SMS verschicken.
Stellt euch das mal vor, kostenlose SMS.
Und man musste den Leuten damals schon erklären, Leute, ihr erzählt den absoluten Blödsinn, das ist keine SMS.
Das ist eine Textnachricht, das hat mit SMS nichts zu tun.
Aber gut, die Leute haben es halt nicht gecheckt, kostenlose SMS, konntest du damals verstehen.
Schreibt ihr euch das vor, kostenlose SMS.
Und da sind die alle drauf aufgesprungen.
Gut, die haben es aber auch clever gemacht.
Die haben es aber auch clever gemacht.
Also, ob die etwas gekostet hat, keine Ahnung.
Die haben die Telefonnummer als ID benutzt.
Das war der erste dieser ganzen Messenger hier, die wir sehen.
Gut, China-Chinesen-Zeug, weiß ich nicht, da musstest du dich wahrscheinlich auch mit deinem Fingerabdruck damals schon registrieren.
Das waren aber die ersten, die sinnvoll gemacht haben.
Und zwar mit der Telefonnummer.
Das ist vielleicht aus Datenschutzgründen nicht sinnvoll, aber aus Boomer-Einfachheitshalber-User-Nutzungssicht ist das das Beste.
Du brauchst keine zusätzliche Nummer.
Das ist ja auch eines der Dinger, warum sich WhatsApp aus meiner Sicht durchgesetzt hat.
China-Chinesen sind immer noch vorne.
WhatsApp, guckt euch an.
Fiber, ist das?
Es sagt mir gar nichts.
Ist das was Russisches?
Was ist Fiber?
Okay, jetzt ist ICQ komplett, fast schon bedeutungslos wieder.
WeChat, okay, die China-Chinesen, die China-Chinesen holen noch mehr auf.
Line sagt mir gar nichts mehr, Tango Eye-Message.
Okay, Eye-Chat würde jetzt enttäuschen.
Jetzt kommen wir so langsam in das, wie ich das auch im Kopf habe.
We-Weep-Chat, genau.
So langsam, aber sicher müsste sich Blackberry doch mal verabschieden jetzt.
Alter, wie WhatsApp flutscht, man.
Muss ich mal überlegen.
Die China-Chinesen haben jetzt doppelt.
Die hatten wahrscheinlich beides parallel installiert, oder?
Hier hatten sie noch die Kontakte und das war das Neue.
Und WhatsApp, Alter, guckt mal, wie WhatsApp abgeht, man.
The most useless Ding überhaupt.
War der Facebook-Messenger nicht früher auch irgendwas anderes?
Haben die das nicht einfach, haben die dafür nicht auch irgendwas übernommen?
Alter, was ist mit dem Facebook-Messenger, man?
Alter, okay, jetzt kommt langsam Telegram.
Okay, aber WhatsApp innerhalb von drei Jahren von 0 auf 100.
Und hier unten sind die Leute so, null, ich habe doch nichts zu verbergen.
Warum braucht man sowas?
Nee, nee, wir bleiben bei WhatsApp.
Okay, Blackberry hat es jetzt erledigt.
Snapchat.
Es gab doch, Moment, Leute, gab es nicht zwischenzeitlich auch mal Kick-Messenger?
Also hat nichts mit diesen billigen Klamotten zu tun.
Gab es nicht auch mal Kick-Messenger, wo die Leute immer versucht haben,
auf den ganzen Pornseiten die Leute zu scammen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jemals verbreitet war, aber das gab es doch mal.
Kick mal kurz zu sehen, ja, Müll da, weg.
Alter, man muss sich das mal überlegen.
Guck mal, 1,5 Milliarden User, 1,5 Milliarden.
Das ist übertrieben heftig.
Und wir reden jetzt hier, also, die Amis würden da Billion zu sagen,
aber die haben sowas auch nicht mehr alle.
1,5 Milliarden User, Mann.
Und dass Facebook-Messenger so groß ist, ist mir gar nicht bewusst.
Die ganzen Boomer dieser Welt sind wahrscheinlich im Facebook-Messenger.
Leute, ich muss euch sagen, da seht ihr mal, wie rückständig ich eigentlich bin.
Und zwar, ich habe weder WhatsApp jemals installiert gehabt,
noch habe ich jemals den Facebook-Messenger installiert gehabt,
noch WeChat, noch Tencent, iMessage habe ich, gut kommt mit dem iPhone,
Skype hatte ich auch, Snapchat hatte ich auch noch nie, Viber noch nie,
Telegram noch nie, Line noch nie und den Blackberry-Messenger auch noch nie,
Signal, ich weiß gar nicht, ob Signal da jemals auftauchen wird,
vielleicht ab 2020 oder so.
Es zählen wahrscheinlich alle Facebook-User, ja, das kann sein,
weil ich kenne niemand, der täglich den Facebook-Messenger verwendet,
wobei ich das gar nicht, ich weiß, das muss existieren,
ich habe halt keine Ahnung von Facebook, weil ich bin nicht auf Facebook aktiv,
Facebook und WhatsApp und Zeug nicht, also, ja.
Hier, die ganzen Zoomer sind bei Snapchat.
Und warum sind die bei Snapchat?
Weil man bei Snapchat ja Bilder angeblich mit einem Verfallsdatum versehen kann.
Die Leute haben ja auch damals, wie bescheuert eigentlich auch,
nicht nur Boomer sind, ganz ehrlich, die anderen sind auch nicht besser.
Die sind wirklich nicht besser.
Wer ernsthaft glaubt, dass man bei Snapchat keine Bilder abgreifen kann,
also, naja.
Alter, WhatsApp ist halt, WhatsApp hat einfach jetzt seit langer Zeit
schon so die kritische Masse, jeder hat jetzt nur noch WhatsApp,
weil alle anderen bei WhatsApp sind.
Siehst du jetzt richtig, guck.
Die Leute müssen zu WhatsApp, weil alle anderen bei WhatsApp sind.
Discord, Discord, guck mal da.
Man muss sich mal überlegen, Discord ist da drinne erst seit 2020
noch gar nicht so lange.
Also quasi hier, wo Corona in vollem Gange war.
Line, was ist eigentlich Line?
Okay, Telegram holt ein bisschen auf.
Guckt mal, ganz im Ernst, wenn man hier online aktiv
und im Gaming Bereich aktiv ist, denkt man immer,
Discord wäre so da oben irgendwo, ist es aber letztendlich gar nicht.
Discord ist natürlich trotzdem verbreitet,
das hat 187 Millionen User.
Aber im Vergleich zu den großen Plattformen,
Snapchat, iMessage, Telegram, Facebook lasse ich mal außen vor,
wahrscheinlich zählt jeder Facebook-Account auch als Messenger-User
und WhatsApp ist es halt gar nicht so groß.
Ja, fand ich tatsächlich ganz interessant.
WeChat, war es nicht so, dass die Leute von WeChat gebannt haben,
weil sie bei Demonstrationen mitgemacht haben?
Irgendwas wurde bei den China-Chinesen gesperrt
und wenn du irgendwie keinen Zugang zu WeChat mehr hast,
dann kannst du ja fast noch nicht mal einkaufen gehen.
Keine Ahnung.
Es müssten schon mehr gewesen sein als 5 Millionen, eher 5 Milliarden wahrscheinlich.
Ich weiß nicht, was das gekostet hat.
Facebook bei WhatsApp.
Was hat Facebook von WhatsApp, was haben die gekauft?
Anfang 2014 schon 17 Milliarden.
19 Milliarden Leute.
Das ist wahrscheinlich als heutiger Sicht absolute Schnäppchen gewesen.
Und auch nicht Billen, wie die Amis immer sagen.
Also die Amis sagen ja Billen, ich meine aber Milliarde.
Weniger als Twitter.
Ja, das stimmt voll.
Aber es war schon 2014.
So, also was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Ja, kann man sich gar nicht ausdenken.
Es könnte nichts damit zu tun haben, was die Leute da drüber schreiben.
Beziehungsweise um zu analysieren, was die Leute so machen und wollen und tun.
Weil die Daten werden selbstverständlich nicht verwendet für irgendwelche Zwecke.
Das ist genauso wie Microsoft sicherlich von Windows keine Sachen mitliest.
Du kannst Twitter gar nicht mehr kaufen.
Schau mal die Katze, wo? Welche?
Okay, ja, der sieht auch schon alt aus.
Es ist eine Sie, okay.
Ich bin Victoria und das ist Flossi.
Lass mich mal überraten.
Sieben.
Krass.
Nee, 26 müssten es dann sein.
Sie ist fast 27.
Sie ist halt schon langsam und hängt ein bisschen rum.
Ich glaube, die jüngste meine ist auch 14 oder so.
Und das merkst du halt schon.
Die ist halt nicht so schnell und legt den ganzen Tag rum.
Die Katze macht auch um 22 Uhr Bett.
So muss das sein, das ist nicht nur bei alten Katzen so, es gibt immer was die Katze will, es ist ja nicht so, als könnte man sich das aussuchen.
Okay, das ist die alteste Katze.
Ich bin so dumm zum Programmieren, das denke ich mir auch immer, aber trotzdem kommt meistens irgendetwas raus.
Ich bin so dumm zum Programmieren, das denke ich mir immer, aber trotzdem kommt meistens irgendetwas raus.
Ich bin so dumm zum Programmieren, das denke ich mir auch immer, aber trotzdem kommt meistens irgendwas raus.
Ich bin so dumm zum Programmieren, das denke ich mir auch immer, aber trotzdem kommt meistens irgendetwas raus.
Machen wir hier nochmal einen großen Kreis.
Ist die Frage, wieviel Monatsgehälter? Wahrscheinlich 12.
Ihr habt super toll mitgemacht. Ihr wart eine tolle Klasse. Man hat gemerkt, ihr kennt euch schon super aus im Wald.
Ihr seid teilweise richtige Waldspezialisten. Bleibt daran, machts weiter so. Habt weiterhin Interesse vom Wald.
Ich wünsche euch jetzt einen schönen Nachhauseweg zurück in die Schule. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Alles klar.
Auf Wiedersehen Schernfelder Schule.
Die sind wirklich nur so brav, weil die Kamera dabei war.
Das ist die perfekte Mischung. Jetzt kann ich genau das, was ich sechs Jahre lang in der Berufsschule gelernt habe, mit beiden Ausbildungen zusammen hier anwenden.
Gibt es auch nur so. Kann man jetzt auch nicht mit einer normalen Forstwitzarbeit vergleichen, weil die haben das auch nicht.
Kann man nicht mit einem normalen Schreiner vergleichen, weil der das nicht hat, sondern das gibt es halt wirklich nur hier im Walderlebniszentrum.
Im Walderlebniszentrum.
Ich meine, immerhin eins muss man ja mal sagen, auch wenn es überhaupt nicht ein Job für mich wäre.
Das ist ja auch alles in Ordnung. Der arbeitet den ganzen Tag.
Also ein Trend, den ich in diesen Videos feststelle, ist es gibt eine riesen Diskrepanz zwischen Jobs, wo tatsächlich gearbeitet wird und wo so getan wird, als ob gearbeitet wird.
Irgendwelche Bullshit-Schwätzer, Jobs, die irgendwie den Eindruck machen, als sind sie so super beschäftigt und den ganzen Tag am machen, aber eigentlich machen sie den halben Tag nichts.
Und Jobs, die tatsächlich von morgens bis abends unterwegs sind und am arbeiten.
Man kann schlecht jeden Tag.
Wenn man das hier mal durchguckt, wir haben jetzt total viel Zeug und schon angeguckt, da hast du zum Beispiel solche Sachen hier zwischendrin, wie der E-Commerce-Junior-Manager, den hatten wir zum Beispiel.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern. Der hat irgendwie den halben Tag lang eine HTML, was war das? Der hat irgendwie einen Button in HTML copypaste den ganzen Tag.
Und da denke ich mir so, was macht der eigentlich den ganzen Tag? Und hier auf der anderen Seite haben wir den Typ, der die Klos repariert, der war den ganzen Tag unterwegs.
Den Schulkindern erzählen, dass man was gegen den Klimawandel machen muss und dann fährt man selber viel mit.
Zählst du dich als jemand, der den ganzen Tag arbeitet, du?
Das liegt aber auch daran, das habe ich aber auch schon öfters gesagt, dass du, wenn du einen Beruf hast, wo du dich konzentrieren musst, also wenn du beispielsweise irgendwas, nehmen wir mal an, du musst irgendwas programmieren.
Aber du kannst das nicht acht Stunden am Tag machen. Niemand kann sich acht Stunden am Tag geistig komplett konzentrieren, um da sinnvolle Sachen auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Das kriegst du vielleicht zwei, zweieinhalb Stunden am Tag hin. Der Rest ist halt dann beiweg, dass das gemacht werden muss.
Von Daily Meetings, bis Gruppenrunden, bis Retrospektive, bis Ticketbearbeitungen, bis irgendwelche Sprintplanungen, bis irgendwelche anderen Absprachen und solche Geschichten.
Also du bist schon den ganzen Tag irgendwie beschäftigt, aber so wirklich produktiv arbeiten machst du vielleicht zweieinhalb Stunden am Tag, weil du kannst dich auch einfach gar nicht länger am Stück konzentrieren, das funktioniert nicht.
Im Auto steht, da habe ich halt immer eine Ausrede gefunden, dass man Auto fährt.
Die Kündigung ist noch nicht raus, die Kündigung ist dann, ist hier raus. Also die werde ich wahrscheinlich hier abgeben nächste Woche dann.
Gut, ich will Werkzeug mitnehmen. Ah, heute will ich danach direkt zum Einkaufen fahren. Und so bin ich halt doch jedes Mal mit dem Auto gefahren.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, also wenn, dann muss man es konsequent machen, Auto verkaufen und nur Fahrrad fahren. Ja, dann habe ich halt mein Auto verkauft und das Fahrrad gekauft.
Chainlock, gute Idee.
Schönen Feierabend.
Da flitzt es, das flitzt.
Leute, habe ich euch erzählt, dass ich mein Auto kaputt gemacht habe, wo ich den gerade Fahrrad fahren sehe.
Habe ich euch erzählt, dass ich mein neues Auto kaputt gemacht habe.
Den Reifen, den Reifen und die Felge ein bisschen. Also, ich habe das Auto jetzt seit drei Monaten ungefähr.
Und ich habe es geschafft über den Bordstein zu fahren, so mit 50 kmh ungefähr.
Und da ist der Reifen geplatzt.
Ja, richtig, richtig 3-Head, aber richtig 3-Head Leute hier.
Da ist der Reifen geplatzt. Oder was weiß ich, ob der geplatzt ist, aber da hat ein Loch gehabt. Vielleicht hat er sich auch aufgerieben oder so.
Ich glaube, da ist geplatzt.
Da ist ein Reifenloch an der Seite. So und ich habe den dann versucht zu fixen mit diesem mitgelieferten Reifenfixkit,
dass ich zur Werkstatt komme. Das hat natürlich nicht funktioniert, weil das Loch an der Seite war.
Das ist komplett aufgerissen, riesengroß, kannst du vergessen.
Ja, komplett im Arsch. Zumindest, ich bin dann quasi mehr oder weniger auf der Felge heimgefahren in die Werkstatt.
Die haben dann gesagt, hey, wir müssen jetzt gucken, ob die Felge kaputt ist.
Und Ersatzreifen gibt es nicht mehr, habe ich nicht mehr. Und außerdem kann ich Ersatzreifen auch nicht einfach auswechseln.
Das Auto ist mega schwer.
So, zumindest haben die mir dann erzählt, vielleicht ist die Felge kaputt.
Kostet irgendwie noch mal 400 Euro extra. Dann muss der Reifen getauscht werden.
Plus theoretisch empfiehlt Fiat beide Reifen zu tauschen.
Nope. Fiat empfiehlt beide Seiten Reifen zu tauschen an einer Achse, auch wenn nur einer kaputt ist.
Weil ansonsten das Bremssystem irgendwie Probleme machen könnte.
Oh, easy. So, da habe ich es in der Werkstatt abgegeben.
Zwei Tage später konnte ich es wieder abholen, war gefixt. Und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Wisst ihr, was ich danach festgestellt habe? Ich hätte nichts davon machen müssen.
Ich hätte nichts davon machen müssen, weil ich habe eigentlich...
Ich habe eigentlich das hier, während ich noch in der Garantie bin.
Und ich habe in meinem Auto einen Assist Knopf an der Decke.
Guckt mal. Den sieht man jetzt hier nicht.
Am Spiegel ist ein Assist Knopf. Der hätte ich einfach drauf drücken müssen.
Und dann hätten die mir jemanden vorbeigeschickt, hätten mich abgeschleppt,
hätten mir sogar ein Ersatzfahrzeug gegeben für zwei Tage.
Aber auch nicht for free, doch. Glaub ich zumindest.
Ja. Also habe ich jetzt halt verkackt, aber auf der anderen Seite
jetzt habe ich das Auto wieder und alles ist gut.
Was hat er denn? Was hat er denn geschrieben?
Okay, das war so schlimm, dass das gelöscht werden muss.
Okay, Achtung, Achtung.
Modges, kann ich mir das angucken? Ohne dass was passiert?
Ich bin jetzt neugierig. Was hat er denn geschrieben?
Egal, ich gucke jetzt drauf.
Ist nicht schlimm. Ich habe sogar selbst auf Twitter geschrieben,
ich bin der schlechteste Autofahrer. Das geht.
Ich kann euch sogar erklären, wie ich das auf die Reihe gekriegt habe
mit gegen den Bordstein fahren.
Also es ist ja relativ kalt draußen und an dem Tag war auch,
also es war glücklicherweise morgens um acht, da ist keiner unterwegs.
Also Scheibe war am Anfang gefroren, ich habe das Auto vorklimatisieren lassen
und alles gut und dann passiert es halt, dass wenn es kalt draußen ist,
dass die Scheibe nicht nur außen gefroren ist, sondern innen sich
auch so ein bisschen Wasser bildet und es läuft dann so die Scheibe runter.
Also was habe ich gemacht? Ich habe Lappen genommen,
während ich am Fahren war und wollte die Scheibe an der Seite abputzen
und aus irgendwelchen High IQ Gründen bin ich auf die Idee gekommen,
das in so einer leichten Kurve zu machen und ich habe schon rumgelenkt,
also ich habe nicht genug rumgelenkt, ich habe rumgelenkt,
habe den Lappen genommen und wollte die Scheibe abputzen
und ich habe halt dann nicht weit genug rumgelenkt und dann bin ich dann
quasi auf so eine, mit dem Reifen auf so eine Bordsteinbegrenzung draufgefahren
und ich habe das auch direkt gemerkt, also es hat halt ordentlich gemacht Wumms,
ist dann so ein bisschen abgeprallt davon wahrscheinlich
und es hat ordentlich gemacht Wumms und ich habe direkt danach gemerkt,
auf der rechten Seite fühlt es sich aber irgendwie komisch an
und nach ein paar hundert Metern mehr habe ich schon gemerkt,
dass es sich komisch anhört und dann dachte ich mir,
hoffentlich habe ich keinen platten Reifen
und nach ein paar hundert Metern mehr habe ich schon gehört Wupp Wupp Wupp Wupp
Scheiße Alter, Dubstep Reifen ja, aber die Felge war nicht kaputt
doch doch doch zeigt er auch, der hat dann auch Warnung angezeigt
Tire Pressure Tire Pressure Low
doch hat er angezeigt Tire Pressure Low
und sogar in der App hat man es gesehen
zumindest die Felge hat es überlebt, das einzige was an der Felge jetzt noch ist
ein paar Kratzer, Warnung im Zabbix bekommen
ne aber in meinem Home Assistant habe ich tatsächlich die Warnung angezeigt bekommen
weil in meinem Home Assistant habe ich ja ein Dashboard, was ungefähr so aussieht
und da sieht man hier Reifendruck
da hat dann hier Reifendruck gestanden
da stand da nicht Error, da stand irgendwas anderes
hab vergessen was da stand, das hat er angezeigt
zumindest die Felge ist nicht kaputt, die hat aber Kratzer
ist aber nicht schlimm, die haben das in der Werkstatt überprüft, meint die
ist alles noch gerade und funktioniert noch
ich frage mich aus welchem Material die Felgen sind
ich hab das Gefühl, die sind nicht mehr rein aus Metall
sondern das ist irgendeine Mischung, weil
die sind so ein bisschen gebröselt
also an der Seite, wo ich dagegen gefahren bin
ist so ein bisschen abgebröselt von der Felge
gut vielleicht ist es auch weil es Alu ist
also es hat sich nicht verbogen, sondern es ist einfach abgebröselt an der Stelle
wo zu viel Druck drauf, also wo der Aufschlag war
komisch, weiß ich auch was die sind
wir können gucken aus was meine Felgen sind
Moment
wir gucken
wir gucken einfach mal aus was meine Felgen sind
verkaufst du deine alte 1080 Ti?
nö
konfigurieren
äh, nein, nein, nein, nein, den 500 E brauchen wir
500, 500 E, wo ist er denn überhaupt?
ja
wie bescheuert
hä?
ok, da kann man jetzt nämlich die Felgen auswählen
also hier
Leichtmetall Felgen mit Diamantfinish
sind das die, die ich auch hab?
zeig mal her
sieht, sieht ein bisschen, sieht ein bisschen so aus
nee, die sind anders aus, meine Felgen sind anders aus Leute, das sind die nicht
ok
ich will jetzt wissen, was ich für Felgen hab, Sekunde, Sekunde
konfigurieren
hä, nee?
wähl ich das falsche Auto aus, kann das sein?
ich bin nicht so blöd mein Auto auszuwählen?
nee, so sehen meine Felgen auch nicht aus
sieht man die jetzt hier?
ja, so sehen meine, das, so sehen die aus, so sehen die aus, so sehen die aus, ok
so sehen die aus
16, 16 Zoll Leichtmetall, ja gut, da weiß ich jetzt aber trotzdem nicht aus was die, aus was die sind
ist immer Alu, alles klar, Sixhead Chat weiß Bescheid
ja für den Preis hab ich das ja auch nicht gekauft
am besten war mein, also ich hab bezahlt, ich glaub 25.500
oder 23.000, Chat ich hab's euch erzählt, ich sag mal 25.000 ungefähr hab ich glaub ich bezahlt
warte mal, ich hab's auf Twitter, ich weiß, auf Twitter hab ich gepostet, was gekostet
also aktuell hab ich irgendwie 7500 Kilometer oder sowas
25.200 habe ich bezahlt
also mal, also Prämie und so gibt's ja dieses Jahr noch
ist es natürlich eine ordentliche Summe ja
ja ja 2021 könnte sogar 2022 Baujahr sein
ich weiß gar nicht genau
die Umweltprämie gibt's weiterhin ist aber weniger
ja weiß ich auch nicht warum ich das aktiviert habe
ja aber da guck ich jetzt nicht rein
Usa, danke schön für den Zapp
so ok also
Problem mit der Umweltprämie ist, dass es nicht um das Abschließen quasi des Vertrages geht
sondern dann wann du das einreichst was halt ziemlich bescheuert ist
zum Beispiel wenn ich jetzt ein Auto verbindlich kaufe dieses Jahr noch bekomme ich die Umweltprämie erst
wenn ich es habe und den Antrag eingereicht habe und es zählt quasi wann der Antrag dort eingeht
das heißt ich kriege auf jeden Fall nicht mehr die volle Prämie für dieses Jahr
und dementsprechend glaube ich haben sich da bestimmt auch ein paar Leute zurückgehalten
weil die sich gedacht haben keine Ahnung ob das noch versiviert oder nicht
was weg fällt ist für Hybridautos fällt es mit der Prämie komplett weg
und ich glaube für Elektroautos ab 40.000 Euro fällt es glaube ich auch weg
oder waren es 60.000 Euro weiß ich aus dem Kopf jetzt gerade nicht
Kriegt man noch Zuschutz für Ladestationen? Nee das gibt es nicht aber es gibt die Möglichkeit an manchen Stellen kostenlos zu laden
zum Beispiel beim Ikea kannst du kostenlos laden
natürlich sollte man dann nach Möglichkeit auch in Ikea gehen
weil die machen das ja nicht einfach aus Nächstenliebe
also das ging noch ich bin aber auch schon vor zwei oder drei Monaten da gewesen
das ging noch beim Ikea wenn denn frei ist was meistens nicht ist
hat deine Arbeit keine Ladestation? Nö
über 50.000 war es ja
also ganz ehrlich ich habe überhaupt keine Probleme mit der Reichweite weil ich das Auto ja absichtlich gekauft habe
weil ich nur hier bei mir in der Gegend rumfahre
wenn ich jetzt ein Auto sag mal ich wäre jetzt irgendwie Versicherungsvertreter oder sowas
würde ich im Leben nicht machen aber theoretisch angenommen
ich wäre super krasse IT Consultant und wäre den ganzen Tag quer durch Deutschland unterwegs
dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich auch kein Elektroauto kaufen
also wenn ich wirklich jeden Tag mehrere hundert Kilometer fahre
dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich kein Elektroauto kaufen
auch wenn das theoretisch vielleicht geht weil die Ladeinfrastruktur ist ja mittlerweile ganz brauchbar
ich gucke immer in der App also immer irgendwo was in Reichweite
aber ganz ehrlich dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich kein Elektroauto kaufen
aber ansonsten ist das für mich das beste Auto
ich fahre am Tag wenn ich überhaupt am Tag fahre
wahrscheinlich ist es pro Tag gerechnet bei mir auch bescheuert
weil ich fahre manche ich fahre viele Tage gar nicht
und wenn dann fahre ich was einkaufen mal irgendwo zum Wandern hin
also alles immer weit unter hundert Kilometer dafür ist das super
ne dafür ist das super
also eine Sache muss man aber halt auch sagen jetzt im Winter jetzt wo es so richtig kalt ist
ist die Akkuleistung ein bisschen geringer
also man verbraucht ein bisschen mehr weil man eben Heizung und alles an hat
und der Akku muss ja auch geheizt werden und so Zeug
aber auch der hat auch gefühlt ein bisschen weniger Kapazität
also sonst wenn ich so zum Wandern fahre brauche ich 7-8% vom Akku
also in eine Richtung und jetzt brauche ich teilweise 15-16% vom Akku
aber jetzt ist halt auch minus 8 Grad Heizung an alles also das ist schon ein Unterschied
das merkt man also man kommt deutlich weniger weit wenn es kalt ist
was aber für mich kein Problem ist weil das alles immer noch wunderbar in der Reichweite liegt
das kann ich dir so genau nicht sagen aber so über den Daumen gebeilt sind 7-8% vom Akku
ob das jetzt nur bei von 100 auf 90 ist oder auch von 50 auf 40 das kann ich dir so unkopflich sagen
vielleicht aber insgesamt fährst du trotzdem wenn es kalt ist kannst du nicht so weit fahren
aber Elektroauto war sinnvoll und was halt auch cool ist zum Beispiel dass ich die Heizung anschalten kann
oder so dass ich die Heizung anschalten kann über Home Assistant bzw. über die App
das ist halt praktisch gerade jetzt minus 8 Grad draußen ich guck mal kurz wie kalt es hier draußen ist
lass mal kurz schauen es ist minus 7,22 ich habe eine Wetterstation draußen hängen
bei mir mittlerweile im Hof am Dach minus 7,5 Grad und da ist natürlich immer die Scheibe dicht
immer kannst du gar nichts dagegen machen und da drücke ich einfach bei mir in der App oder im
Home Assistant auf Heizen dann gehe ich 5 bis 10 Minuten später ans Auto und die Scheibe ist frei
das Tor kann ich gerade nicht machen ich will ja mein Hof da automatisch öffnen und schließbar machen
das kann ich gar nicht machen es ist mir zu kalt draußen hast du keine Garage doch ich habe eine Garage
aber da passt das Auto nicht rein die Garage hat der Opa mal irgendwann gebaut für seine kleine
Karre und da ist das Auto zu breit für du würdest vielleicht vielleicht mit eingeklappten Spiegeln
würdest du vielleicht gerade so reinkommen aber dann kriegst du die Tür nicht auf ja der ist zu breit
also mein altes Auto war mit Außenspiegeln ungefähr ungefähr so breit wie mein neues ohne Spiegel
also es ist schon es ist schon links und rechts so das ist schon mal irgendwie 30 cm breiter das Ding
insgesamt ungefähr so über den Daumen 20 20 cm aber das passt nicht in die Garage rein oder 30 ja das ist halt schon ein Unterschied
passt nicht in die Garage rein aber auch nicht schlimm weil das rein und rausfahren mit der Garage
ist eh eklig ich fahre einen Hof weil im Hof hängt auch die Ladestation ja klar links und rechts
und dann fällt die Wand runter die Ladestation hängt ja auch im Hof bisschen unterm Dach ich fahre
einfach in Hof rein und schließt das da an deswegen will ich ja auch das Hoftor elektrisch machen
kann ich dann draußen auf dem Display auf dem Display vom Auto drücken Hoftor öffnen oder Knopf
drücken oder so oder oder Voice Assistant sagen Hoftor auf
ne interessiert mich so überhaupt nicht
ne kein Ding ich hab den ich hab den Motor schon neue Garage bauen ja wenn ich irgendwie noch mal 15.000 Euro
oder so ausgeben will keine Ahnung was es kostet in der Garage zu bauen dann würde ich das machen aber
ne das lass ich's lassen wir bleiben gibt keine neue Garage nur elektrisch ich brauche ich brauche
keine Sensoren weil ich habe die Möglichkeit das über die Fiat App zu machen also beziehungsweise
über meine eigenen selbst programmierte Home Assistant Integration weil ich mit bekomme wenn der
Fiat GPS gewisse GPS Koordinaten rein fährt da kann ich auf und zu machen alternativ kann ich über
Voice Command öffnen oder mit einem Knopf oder übers Display
mit Kamerakennzeichenerkennung ne ich brauche keine Kamerakennzeichenerkennung weil das nur für mein Auto
funktioniert also ich bin ja eingelogt bei Fiat und ich hab dort über den Account die GPS
Koordinaten und man kann in der App ein Radius definieren wo es dann eine Benachrichtigung schickt
wenn das Auto sich in diesem Bereich begibt oder aus dem Bereich herausfährt und auf diese
Benachrichtigung kann ich reagieren mit Home Assistant dann könnte ich da drüber das Hoftor auf
machen mache ich aber nicht ich mache es höchstwahrscheinlich über Voice Command ich habe ja den
Voice Command Button auf dem Lenkrad drückst du drauf dann kannst du sagen oder man kann auch sagen
Hey Fiat richtig cringe alter ich benutze nie dieses Wake Up Word Hey Fiat klingt richtig
bescheuert ne ich könnte auch sagen Hey Fiat macht das Hoftor auf oder sowas in der Richtung
wobei das halt nur funktioniert wenn du ein iPhone oder ein Android per Carplay oder Android
Auto drüber gepaart hast aber gut das muss ich ausprobieren das muss ich ausprobieren wie das
am besten funktioniert wahrscheinlich werde ich am Ende einfach ein Knopf drücken
ok was können wir uns noch anschauen also wir haben den Waldpädagoge noch gar nicht fertig
geguckt was verdient er denn am Ende jetzt ich wollte mietfrei sein ich wollte irgendwie
was eigenes haben und dann ist mir die Idee das ist ja wirklich Mini Haus gekommen Tiny House
das ist jetzt mein mobiles Tiny House das ist mobil? Ach das kann man bewegen das Haus oder?
Februar wohne ich drin vor August letztes Jahr habe ich angefangen das zu bauen und dann habe
ich jetzt hier das Grundstück selber gekauft das ist jetzt mein eigenes ja gebaut ist es auf dem
Sattelauflieger auf den 30 Tonnen ach man kann das fahren? Ja man sieht es ist natürlich
immer noch nicht fertig seitdem der Rohbau eigentlich steht und auch vor allem seitdem
ich im Februar drin wohne ist nicht mehr viel passiert ist halt immer wieder mal so was ich
schaffe schaffe ich was ich nicht schaffe schaffe ich nicht also man sieht auch von innen dass noch
nicht alles fertig ist aber cool ist das irgendwie schon ich meine ich würde wahrscheinlich nicht
drinne wohnen wollen auch wenn es wahrscheinlich recht so eng eng und gemütlich so ist aber ich
glaube ich habe nicht genug Platz für mein ganzes Zeug aber er hat irgendwie was mir ist wichtig in
mein Haus gewesen dass ich alles so habe wie normalen Haus aber mir war wichtig dass ich eine
Küche habe wo ich zu dritt oder zu viert kochen kann was da leicht möglich ist mir war wichtig
dass ich jetzt zu viert essen kann. Ohne Scheiß von innen ok die Wand sieht da von innen sieht das
gar nicht so klein aus. Und auch hier zu viert mit Freunden rum sitzen kann ohne dass es jetzt
eng wird. Ja war wichtig dass ich ein normales Sofa habe was ich nutzen kann das war eigentlich so
das wichtigste. Hi IQ Musik im Hintergrund
Aber das hat er doch nie im Leben alle das kannst du doch gar nicht alleine bauen oder?
Der hat da bestimmt viel gemacht aber das schaffst du doch arbeitstechnisch gar nicht so ein Haus
alleine zu bauen oder? Ich kann das schlecht einschätzen aber das kannst du doch gar nicht alleine
machen. Ja. Na gut er ist Schreiner vielleicht. Die Bergwacht. Alter der ist aber echt aktiv
der ist von morgens bis 16 Uhr im Wald und macht da Zeug und dann macht er abends noch irgendwie
freiwillig Bergwacht oder sowas. Der hat aber echt was zu tun. Da wollen wir das Szenario jetzt nochmal
durchspielen. Der hustelt ja. Ich werde sie jetzt mal abtasten wenn sie irgendwo Schmerzen haben
dann einfach Bescheid geben ok. Auf Stunden gerechnet habe ich es noch nie es ist Jan Amtsarbeit
die unglaublich viel Spaß macht die wunderschön ist da zu arbeiten es ist auch ein Ausgleich zur
Arbeit also das würde ich nie in Stunden aufrechnen was das ist. Also ich finde meine Tätigkeit
lohnt sich schon auf jeden Fall von dem was ich mache und was ich machen darf und mit den Kindern
zu arbeiten dieses Feedback zu bekommen aber auch. Also der ist wirklich von morgens bis abends am
Start. Was ich mir noch wünschen würde ist wirklich eine finanzielle Anerkennung für das was wir hier
machen aber ich will hier eigentlich umgehen weg. Ich hoffe dass es noch die Aufstiegschancen mit
dem Meister gibt und dass mir die geschaffen werden. Der Waldpädagogen Meister.
Da kannst du wirklich nicht allzu große Sprünge mit machen.
Bleibt nicht viel übrig. Der ist am Ende auf Null. Was er fährt er fährt eh Fahrrad und halt
wahrscheinlich muss er ja irgendwie auch in Wald. Das wird er mit dem Auto machen nicht mit dem E-Fahrrad.
Da war es. Das war mein Tag hier im Walderlebniszentrum Schernfeld. Hier geht es jetzt zum anderen Video.
Alles klar. Jetzt müssen wir auch was an Waldpädagogen machen. Ich wusste bis vorhin gar nicht
dass sowas existiert. What your boss can track about human steams. Keine Ahnung ist mir wurscht.
In Deutschland dürfen sie die Hälfte eh nicht.
Das ist das ist die Musik vielleicht ein bisschen flotter. Bisschen was zackigeres.
Hat jemand schon geballt? Lohnt sich das? Mich interessiert die Chat Einschätzung mehr als was
irgendein Typ auf YouTube sagt. Lohnt sich das nicht? Ich weiß es ist umsonst wenn man es hat.
16 FPS. Das wäre doch mal ein richtig geiles Spiel für meine 4090 zum Einstieg oder?
Was Next-Gen-Update benutzt eine API von Microsoft. Von der Microsoft was sagt man soll sie nicht
für 3D benutzen. Hä wie was was benutzen die? Es würde mich jetzt interessieren was die machen.
Aktuell eidet die nicht mehr. Aktuell ist sie ausgeschaltet. Nein mache ich noch nicht.
Der steht hinter mir. Ich muss das Kabel für die Grafikkarte noch austauschen. Die Festplatte
endlich einbauen und noch die Kabel jetzt ein bisschen anders machen. Staubfänger 5000 Euro
Staubfänger easy. Und als Notfallheizung. Leute ich habe da drin die All in One Wasserkühlung.
Und wenn du volle Pulle also wenn du Benchmarks aufmachst und du hältst die Hand oben drüber
das ist ein Heizlüfter wie im Bad nicht ganz so krass wie im Bad aber es ist ein Heizlüfter.
Ja dass die mit Unreal das machen wollen das weiß ich aber das hat man ja bei Cyberpunk gesehen
dass sie mit ihrem eigenen Kram nicht zurecht kommen. Komm wir gucken uns Weltkit an.
Oder das. Hast du deinen 13900k Undervolt? Nö. Ich glaube auch dass es keine so gute Idee
ist in dem Fall den zu Undervolten weil der ja schon mit ein bisschen mehr Takt als Stock Takt
läuft und wenn ich den zusätzlich noch Ander wollte. Ich meine wir können das mal ausprobieren
kann nichts kaputt gehen aber ich habe da so meine Zweifel dass der nicht Stable ist.
Nee. Ich habe aber auch die Spannung nicht angehoben und ich habe auch nicht super heftig
übertaktet oder so weil das ist aber selbst mit dieser 3 mal 140 Millimeter Lüftergeschichte
ist es jetzt nicht so dass ich viel Spielraum habe was übertakt man geht also ich habe ich habe
den jetzt standardmäßig plus 100 Megahertz laufen also der ist dann quasi wenn alle Kerne
beschäftigt sind hat er maximal 5,5 Gigahertz anstatt 5,4 Gigahertz das habe ich auch durch
durch genudelt mit Prime 95 hat überhaupt keine Probleme mit aber mehr würde ich da
jetzt also ich habe ihn mal übertaktet bis auf 5,7 und da ist er halt relativ schnell
an den 100 Grad dran und taktet schon nicht sogar 5,8 ich habe 5,8 Giga ich habe 5,8 gemacht
5,8 weil der höchste 5,8 muss er nämlich schaffen allein schon von der Theorie her
weil der höchste Boost glaube ich standardmäßig 5,8 ist das heißt er sollte theoretisch auf
allen Kern 5,8 schaffen aber halt nicht bei allen gleichzeitig so deswegen habe ich auf
5,8 übertakt das Ding das war relativ instant an 100 Grad dran und hat sich runtergetakt
auf 5,7 5,6 immer wieder also so viel Luft habe ich da gar nicht nach oben selbst mit
der fetten Wasserkühlung drauf ich meine ich könnte es mal ausprobieren wenn ich den
wenn ich den anderen wollte ob der noch stable ist bei plus 100 megahertz habe ich nicht
wie schaut es in Sachen Leistung aus brutal alle ich habe bisschen übertakt ich habe
40.500 Cinebench Punkte das ist mega krass das Ding also meine meine Wasserkühlung
pustet nicht auf die Grafikkarte weil die zieht die Luft raus das einzige was man halt
sagen könnte okay die würde die zieht dann theoretisch warme Luft raus von der Grafikkarte
aber das ist jetzt nicht so nicht so wild gewesen bis jetzt
zumal er vorne zwei lüfter drin sind die frische luft rein blasen das video habe ich
gesehen und das hat er nicht gezeigt das gezeigt dass die mit 90 watt power limit sehr energieeffizient
ist und man nicht so viel leistung ein büßt dass die genauso ist hat er nicht gezeigt
ob die cpu oder die gpu heiser ist das habe ich tatsächlich noch nicht ausprobiert was
ist denn der beste grafikkartentemperatur test früher gab es dieses was haare berechnet
hat wo man so teppich teppich fasern berechnet hat ich weiß nicht mal wie das heißt ja genau
das meine ich doch genau das meine ich ja ja ja ja das meine ich ist das immer noch ist
das immer noch angesagt für grafikkartentemperatur oder was nimmt man denn so wenn man maximale
grafikkartentemperatur testen will ja hier das mit den das das mit den haben mit den
fangen genau
wahrscheinlich nicht aber warum möchte man das machen wahrscheinlich machst du kürz
oder lang die pumpe kaputt kann ich mir vorstellen
es gab vor ein paar jahren doch mal dieses komische bei wo war das bei toms hardware
oder so den pc in in öl einlegen so als geheimtipp wo ich mir auch gedacht habe mein
gott seid ihr bescheuert alter das wurde damals als geheimtipp verkauft legt ein legt ein pc
doch in öl einer bleibt da schön kalt passen eigentlich dass wir das das video vom bauer
hier dazu wird auch ein pc destilliertes was uwuntu die daseinsberechtigung davon habe
ich noch nicht verstanden weil es ist ja noch nicht mal sonnig sonnig wie besiert ja das
genau stimmt allein wegen den schläuchen kannst du da wahrscheinlich kein öl rein
machen kannst du das liegungstechnik video mit tastatur in der spülmaschine ne aber ich
könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass das funktioniert wird es vielleicht nicht machen
zumal eins muss man echt sagen seitdem ich hier so eine mechanische tastatur am start
habe das verdrecken ist deutlich besser als bei dieser old school mit diesem gummi zeugs
drunter das gummi zeug hat total oft einfach direkt durch die ritzen bekommen und war dann
verdreckt nach ein paar jahren von staub bis vielleicht paar krümel vom essen und mit
dem mit den mechanischen switches da ist ja kein loch quasi das halt einfach ein switch
drauf rubber dome genau so komm eine sache können wir uns mal angucken wir gucken uns
mal ich muss mir das neue svelte video angucken fireship muss uns was erklären svelte 1.0
ist jetzt raus das ist ein wer hätte das gedacht ein weiteres javascript framework allerdings
ein gescheites damit kann man server side rendering kleinzeit rendering und alles in
einem machen und svelte ist epoch lasst uns mal angucken was fireship dazu erzählt das
ist java nicht javascript ups falscher button ist das so ist svelte
ok was ist was ist denn da sonst so blazer alter warum mögen die leute blazer ich kann
es nicht verstehen alter blazer ist echt pence champ und warum ist vue js so schlecht mittlerweile
wobei nicht so schlecht immer top 10 hier guck mal asp.net mögen die meisten leute
nicht aber wahrscheinlich weil die meisten leute asp.net noch kennen aus asp.net zeit
und nicht asp.net core asp.net ah ne moment asp.net core ist ja da oben lull hab ich verguckt
ja ok das verstehe ich asp.net core finde ich nämlich ziemlich nice und asp.net ist
abartig warum microsoft die sachen wieder mal so beschissen benannt hat weiß nur microsoft
guck mal ruby ist genau in der mitte rails ist aber wirklich cool also ich mag rails
rails ist nice verbel ist auch nice guck mal weiter
was mit der musik los
ich kann es mir immer nicht merken bei dieser bezeichnung alter ich kann es mir einfach
nicht mehr bemerken nax also nax gs ist react nax gs is view oder und remix ist dieses dieses
facebook ding ne nicht facebook airbnb oder ach keine ahnung was war remix war das uber
airbnb ne was war remix ach ich blick da nicht mal durch
warum gibt es tausend verschiedene javascript frameworks die zahl ist noch deutlich untertrieben
das ist jetzt neu das war früher noch nicht so die letzte version die ich verwendet habe
war das noch nicht so mit diesem filebase routing und dieser benahmung das ist jetzt
neu das kenne ich noch nicht bloß
was ich gut finde ist was ich gut finde ist dass man jetzt einfach ein und ausschalten
kann pro seite ob man server side rendern will oder nicht warum macht nax kein javascript
framework js champ
der name wäre auf jeden fall schon mal gesetzt
was ist das javascript was ist das schon wieder was ist das für ein wort
was was ist das habe ich noch nie gesehen was ist das schon wieder für eine komische
syntax
das ist typescript das ist in den typescript ding dass es in den typescript stellt ah ok
ich meine mich wundert mich wundert mittlerweile bei javascript nix mehr ja das ist also da
kann alles da ist alles möglich mittlerweile
ich meine mich wundert mittlerweile bei javascript nix mehr ja das ist so da kann alles da ist
alles möglich
man könnte auch einfach craftql verwenden und das jemand anderes für sich machen lassen
ja das ist das tatsächlich ganz nice
also dass das startup mäßige framework dabei ist
dass
Pretty much every modern framework has stolen this feature from Remix,
which itself got the idea from the way every other PHP framework has worked since the beginning of time.
And another piece of bonus news is that SvelteKit is also getting a library very similar to NextAuth for user authentication.
Rich Harris, the creator of Svelte and SvelteKit, works at Versel,
and the team from NextAuth developed this library, which is awesome because that means it's getting world-class tools proven to work at the largest scale.
Overall, SvelteKit is a genre-defining masterpiece.
If you want to penetrate deeper into this topic, stay tuned for a full uncensored tutorial on Beyond Fireship.
This has been the Code Report. Thanks for watching, and I will see you in the next one.
Das wäre eine gute Bezeichnung. Ich wüsste bloß nicht, für was er stehen soll.
Also was ich ja gerne verwende ist SvelteKit, Frontend, ASP.NET Core im Backend.
CraftQL verwende ich ganz gerne.
Also wie könnten wir den Champ-Stack daraus zusammensetzen?
Also SvelteKit beziehungsweise SvelteKit.
Dann haben wir CraftQL mache ich ganz gerne, das Hot Chocolate heißt die Library, vielleicht bringt ihr uns was.
Also ASP.NET Core, ehrlich gesagt als Datenbank, entweder Postgres oder SQLite könnten wir da einbauen, Leute, wie könnten wir daraus Champ bauen?
Den Swag-Stack gibt es schon, P ist Postgres, P ist Postgres, das ist schon mal okay.
ASP.NET Core ist A, okay aber C, H und M, wie kriegt man das da jetzt irgendwie rein?
Gar nicht, oder?
Ah ja, C ist C-Sharp, das ist gut, das ist gut, das finde ich nice, okay.
Aber Svelte hat kein M und hat kein H drin.
CraftQL kann, nee das ist blöd, CraftQL, also das Svelte, der Cap, der Cap-Stack, ich glaube da brauchen wir eine bessere Bezeichnung für, das wird so nichts, das wird so nichts.
Wir nennen das einfach den Meltum, genau wir folgen das nur, dass ich den Champ-Stack erstellen kann.
Wobei, es gibt es doch schon bestimmt, Champ-Stack, die Leute haben doch bestimmt schon sich sowas ausgedacht, Champ-Stack, GitHub.
Okay, das ist anscheinend noch frei, nee da fällt mir jetzt nichts zu ein, wie man daraus Champ machen kann.
Okay, okay, nee C haben wir schon, vielleicht können wir noch irgendwie Cloud oder so mit reinbauen, da ist nirgends irgendwo ein H und ein M drin.
Nee, keine Chance.
Helm-Charts, aber es hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
By the way, warum heißt das eigentlich, hat irgendjemand verstanden warum Helm, warum das Charts heißt, obwohl es eigentlich nur mit Graphen überhaupt nichts zu tun hat?
Warum heißt das eigentlich Charts, das sind ja überhaupt keine Graphen, es ist ja im Prinzip so eine Sammlung, wie installiere ich verschiedene Container zusammen.
Darf man auch, darf man auch Deployment sagen.
Ah, ist Hetzener Cloud, okay das würde tatsächlich funktionieren, das würde tatsächlich funktionieren, aber wir müssen irgendwie unser JavaScript Zeug noch reinkriegen, da bleibt bloß noch M übrig.
Also wir müssen Svelte-Kit irgendwie in M mit reinbekommen, irgendwas mit M, Mobile, ich hab keine Ahnung, da fällt mir nichts ein.
Most Loved, tatsächlich, was ist Most Loved, Most Loved, ich hab keinen Account.
Im Prinzip ist diese Benamung eh immer ziemlich hängen geblieben.
Also ich verstehe unter Charts immer sowas wie beispielsweise ein Tortendiagramm, ja ich will ja nicht irgendein Framework, was mit M ist.
Das heißt der Twitch Chat ist auch ein Graph, weil es eine Ansammlung von einzelnen Textnachrichten in einem Chatraum ist.
Also Graph Driven Twitch Chatting.
Haben wir noch irgendwas, was wir uns anschauen können? Was ist das denn hier?
Reddit versus Wall Street, oh ne, das gucken wir uns jetzt an, 14 Minuten Alter.
Da ging kurzzeitig die Welt unter.
Ach das haben die sogar da drinnen stehen, warum das so.
Aha, na dann.
Ach das sagt ChatGPT, weil ich hab mich nämlich gerade gefragt, ich wollte nämlich gerade sagen, wo da die Visual Representation von sein soll, aber ok.
Ok, das ist, aber ChatGPT ist schon ziemlich, ziemlich high IQ, oder?
Dass die sowas rauskriegt.
Ok, gucken wir uns Wall Street, Wall Street Bats an, auf geht's.
Ist das Voice Acting aus Gothic?
Das ist der Skyrim Sprecher, es hätte auch 1 zu 1 aus Gothic sein können, wobei das sich noch ein bisschen anders anhört.
Das ist auch Skyrim, na gut da lag ich falsch, aber eins muss man ja sagen, also die NPC, also gerade die deutsche Synchro von Gothic war halt schon cool.
Oh ja, das Video kann ich mich noch erinnern.
Leute, seriously, ich war glaube ich noch nie in meinem Leben in einem Gamestop, wem geht's auch noch so?
Ich war korrigiert, es hat sehr regener Remember.
zum Thema Investing und eine Vorliebe für Katzen-T-Shirts.
Keith Gill entschied sich dazu, sein Investment in einem Subreddit namens rslashwallstreetbets zu posten.
Auf Reddit gibt es für gefühlt alles auf der Welt ein Subreddit.
Für Katzenfotos, für Fußfotos, für Leut-
Reddit, das stimmt wohl.
Leute, es gibt Zeug auf Reddit, das will man, das besprechen wir hier lieber nicht.
Und nein, Chainlaw, poste nicht dein Zeug, sonst time-out ich dich wieder.
... hab ich etwa meine Pillen wieder vergessen.
Und halt eben Wallstreetbets.
Ein meme-lastiges Subreddit für Hobby-Investoren, in dem Leute ihre Gewinne, oder meistens Verluste,
posten können.
Hauptsächlich werden aber Wolf of Wallstreet Gifts gepostet und Leute regen mit Shitposten und Beams zum Investieren an.
Und die Leute in der Community nehmen sich gegenseitig Retards und Apes, verständlich.
Denn beispielsweise gibt es da den User analfarma2, ein arbeitsloser Student, mit 110.000 Dollar in seinem Account.
Verdient durch Online-Business.
Macht einen sogenannten YOLO All-in-Move in einer Aktie und macht über eine halbe Million Dollar, mit 19 Jahren.
Nur, um dann alles davon in einem weiteren All-in-Move zu verlieren.
Für die Leute auf Reddit war das pure Unterhaltung.
Und ihm wurde daraufhin geraten, einfach einen grünen Stift zu nehmen und eine Linie auf das Handy zu malen.
Passt schon so.
Oder der User controlled a Narrative, der in seiner Trading-App einen Infinite-Money-Glitch fand,
daraufhin dann alles live-verlaufender Kamera verlor.
Und somit zu-
Was du?
Okay, bei den Videos weißt du ja nie, was jetzt ein bisschen dazu gedichtet ist.
Aber das kann schon alles sein.
...einer lebenden Legende in WallStreetBets wurde.
Ein User hat komplett aus Versehen 110-Money-Glitch, Alter.
Und es gibt natürlich noch den WallStreetBets-Discord.
Okay, KeithGill postete seinen GameStop-Kauf um Subreddit und wurde für seine dumme Investition belächelt und runtergevoted.
Doch er war der Meinung, dass GameStop gar nicht so schlecht aufgestellt ist, wie man meinen könnte.
Die Firma hat genug Geld für die nächsten Jahre.
Die neuen Konsolen kommen mit CD-Laufwerken raus und Spiele werden außerdem immer größer.
Ich kann's kaum erwarten, das neue Fortnite-Update zu spielen.
Dieses gottverdammte-
Hello darkness, my old friend.
Und Leute fangen deshalb wieder an, CDs zu kaufen.
Doch 2020 kam Corona.
Leute prügelten sich um Klopapier, verklappelten den Lockdown überhaupt nicht und die Läden schlossen somit auch.
Und dadurch sank auch der wertvolle GameStop.
Doch KeithGill und Michael Burry hielten die Aktie.
Ja, sie glaubten an ihren Erfolg in der Zukunft.
Tick.
Tock.
Und ihre Geduld zahlte sich-
Warum genau muss der Typ ne Zigarre rauchen im Stream?
Weil das krasses Business ist und so richtig krasse Business-Typen Zigarre rauchen.
Im Oktober 2020 schlägt die Aktie von 8 Dollar auf 13 Dollar.
KeithGills investierten 50.000 Dollar, sind mittlerweile 2 Millionen wert.
Und Leute auf Reddit fingen an, ihn für einen Propheten zu halten.
Und investierten auch in die Aktie.
Und somit wurde die erstmals kleine-
Moment, Moment, Moment, das muss ich jetzt verstehen, was?
KeithGills investierten 50.000 Dollar und ihre Geduld-
Moment.
Der Sieg-
Wie ist?
Tick.
Also, der S ist gestiegen von-
Und ihre Geduld zahlte sich aus.
Am 8.
Oktober 2020 schlägt die Aktie von 8 Dollar auf 13 Dollar.
Auf 13.
Das ist irgendwie, was sind das, 60% oder so, hä?
Quickmuffs, keine Ahnung.
KeithGills investierten 50.000 Dollar, sind mittlerweile-
Warum, warum, wenn, wenn das um 60% steigt, da müssen, müssen wir die ganzen Stonkskenner
unter euch das ja mal erklären.
Wenn es um 60% steigt, warum sind dann aus 50.000 Euro 2,2 Millionen geworden?
Ja, es kommt jetzt, okay.
2 Millionen wert.
Und Leute auf Reddit fingen an, ihn für einen Propheten zu halten.
Und investierten auch in die Aktie.
Und somit wurde die erstmals kleine GME GameStop Gang gegründet.
GameStop bis zum Mond.
GameStop Gang.
Kauft GameStop.
Einfach Leute, die diese Aktie lieben.
Der Kurs fing hier und da dann an zu schwanken.
Keith postete weiterhin monatliche Updates von seinem Investment und die Leute vertrauten
ihm.
Wenn er noch drin ist, dann bin ich es auch, hieß es.
Und dann fiel den Leuten etwas auf.
Ein extrem großer Anteil der Investoren und Hedgefonds ersetzte gegen GameStop.
Also auf den Fall der Aktie.
Hedgefonds sind quasi große Investorenverbände, bei denen die Leute alles aussehen wie der
Typ von Monopoly.
Diese haben beispielsweise damals Milliarden auf den Fall von Toy Saraz gesetzt und somit
dafür gesorgt, dass es diesen Laden heute nicht mehr gibt.
Du hast uns gute Dienste erwiesen, mein Freund.
Außerdem manipulieren sie die Börse nach Weiß, die schon seit Jahren haben technische Mittel,
die der kleine Reddit Anleger nicht hat und können somit regelmäßig konsequenzlos Milliarden
an Geld anmachen.
Die waren sehr unbeliebt bei den Redditen.
Die Hedgefonds versetzten also Milliarden an Dollar auf den Fall von GameStop und läuten
viel auf, dass ein gewisses seltenes Börsenphänomen entstehen könnte.
Der Short Squeeze.
Sehr einfach erklärt.
Ein paar Investorenkrokodile setzen darauf, dass der Preis von Bananen fällt.
Wenn das passiert, machen die Krokodile eine Menge Geld.
Ein paar Affen merken dann, oh, die setzen darauf, dass der Bananenpreis sinkt.
Lasst uns viele Bananen kaufen, dadurch steigt der Preis der Bananen an und die Krokodile
machen Verlust.
Ein paar Krokodile sagen sich dann, okay, wir sind draus aus dem Geschäft und müssen
aussteigen, bevor wir noch mehr verlieren.
Dadurch und durch ein paar sehr komplizierte Börsenprinzipien steigt dann wiederum der
Preis an und noch mehr Krokodile müssen aussteigen und es entsteht eine riesige Kettenreaktion
und der Preis der Bananen könnte die Höhe schießen und das bis in uns endliche.
Bruder.
Bananen.
Die Krokodile setzen dann auf das Phänomen aufmerksam und ungefähr zur selben Zeit kommen
auch die neuen Konsolen auf den Markt und werden ordentlich gehypt.
Und ein Typ, der eigentlich Hundespielzeug produziert, wird Vorsitzender bei Gamestop.
Zwei gute Zeichen für die Firma und der Preis plästete von 19 Dollar auf erstmalig
40 Dollar.
Also wenn der Typ schon mit 60% so viel gemacht hat, der ist jetzt ja Multi-Hunderten-Millionen-Millionär.
Die Krokodile kassierte seine Millionen Profite weiterhin auf Reddit.
Leute machten die ersten Gewinne damit und die Aktie wurde von der jetzt noch größeren
Affenhorde auf Reddit weiter hochgehypt.
Das Magazin VICE widmete dem kleinen Hype den ersten Artikel.
Doch der Mainstream und die großen Hedgewons der Wall Street hatten immer noch nicht die
leiseste Ahnung, was eine kleine Gruppe an Leuten im Internet da fabrizieren.
Und doch dann kam der erste Boss, der Unternehmer Andrew Left, der selber gegen Gamestop setzt,
warnte die Leute von Reddit offen in einem Livestream, dass sie keine Ahnung haben, was
sie da tun und der Preis bald wieder auf 20 Dollar fallen sollte.
Da hat er wahrscheinlich Angst um sein Geld gehabt.
So was kannst du nicht posten in der heutigen Zeit, das wird ja zu Tone gemimt.
Doch ein paar Reddit-User wird die Situation dadurch zu heiß und sie schlossen ihre Position.
Es gibt ein weitverbreitetes Konzept bei WallStreetBets, Diamond Hands.
Diamond Hands heißt die Aktie halten, bis man am Ziel ist, auch wenn Krisen und Hindernisse
kommen.
Und das war das Motto der Redditor.
Und somit schiebte der Preis immer weiter an, es war wie ein Lauffeuer.
Erstens gab es mehr Memes und Shitposting, dann bekam mehr Leute davon mit, investiert
dann Gamestop.
Ist Diamond Hands quasi das Gegenstück zu Hodl, wenn es um Krypto Zeug geht?
Ist das das gleiche, nur anders ausgedrückt?
Die Aktie erreichte schließlich 76 Dollar und die Armee der Affen war nicht mehr aufzuhalten.
26.
Januar.
Elon Musk tweetete Gamestop und verlinkte das Subreddit.
Und die Aktie schoss nach oben.
Erst auf die 243 Dollar, dann auf die 360 Dollar und die Medien fingen überall an davon
zu berichten.
Außerdem sagten sie, dass Andrew Lefthörmer ihre Verkaufsposition geschlossen hat, genauso
wie eines der größten Hedgefonds der Welt.
Doch für die Monkeys of Redditt war das eine Falle.
Sie glaubten, das sei ein Fake-News, um Leute dazuzukriegen, zu verkaufen.
Die Redditor kannten die Regel.
Sie haben sich jahrelang durch sehr intensives Online-Training auf diesen Tag vorbereitet.
Und somit hielten sie weiter die Aktien.
Die Redditor kauften noch mehr, sie wollten noch höher, sie wollten bis zum Mond.
Bislang konnten die großen Player an der Börse nach Belieben agieren.
Jetzt haben die kleinen Anleger sie mit ihren eigenen Waffen geschlagen.
Der Preis stieg schließlich auf 500 Dollar.
Das war wie David gegen Goliath.
Kleine Reddit-User mit Namen wie PotatoInMyAss zwingten die größten Investoren der Welt
durch shitposting und Memes in die Knie.
Goldman warnte daraufhin, dass eventuell die ganze Wirtschaft zusammenbrechen könnte.
Und die Underground GameStop Aktie wurde schließlich neben Tesla und Apple als der meistgehandelten
Aktien der Welt.
Auf dem Weg zum Mond riss die Aktie außerdem andere Firmen wie AMC oder Nokia mit und der
ganze Markt spielte verrückt.
Es herrschte absolutes Chaos auf der WallStreet.
Und doch plötzlich passierte etwas Unerwartetes.
Auf jeglichen Broker-Apps in jedem Land der Welt verschwand plötzlich der Kauf-Button.
Viele Leute kriegten daraufhin Panik und verkauften sofort.
Denn wenn keiner mehr kaufen kann, kann auch der Preis nicht mehr ansteigen.
Außerdem schlossen ein paar Trading Apps automatisch die Position der kleinen Anleger.
Und somit fiel der Aktienpreis innerhalb ein paar Stunden zurück bis auf die 120 Dollar
Mark.
Kurz vor dem Moment, in dem viele Leute fast Millionäre geworden werden.
Ok, erstmal.
Die größte Trading App mit dem Namen Robin Hood bekam den Shitstorm ihres Lebens.
Denn immerhin warben sie damit dem kleinen Anleger eine Chance zum Investieren zu geben.
Doch jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr.
Robin Hood wurde zum Sheriff von Nottingham.
Zu gleichen Zeit versuchten die Massenmedien die GameStop-Geschichte aus den Köpfen der
Leute auszutreiben.
Erst hieß es, dass Reddite anstatt sich auf GameStop jetzt auf Silber fokussierten, was
einfach nicht stimmte.
Dann sind die GameStop-Investoren auf einmal weiße Nazi-Männer und zahlreiche Newsportale
teilgenommen.
Na wenn sonst nichts geht, das geht immer.
Wie gefährlich es ist, Geld zu investieren.
Die Verkäufer der Aktie sind plötzlich die Helden und zahlreiche Investoren beklagen
sich live über die dummen Affen aus dem Subreddit, die die Börse durcheinander gebracht haben.
Daraufhin hagelte es negative Bewertungen von Reddit-Usern für die Trading Apps, nur damit
Google diese mit einem Klick komplett entfernt ist.
Der komplett überflutete WallStreetBets Discord-Server wurde daraufhin wegen Hassrede einfach aus
dem Nichts gelöscht.
Und eine Vielzahl an Bots wurde im Subreddit gefunden, die Leute dazu anregen sollten,
ihre GameStop-Aktien zu verkaufen.
Die Leute auf Reddit hatten das Gefühl, dass sie sich diesmal mit den großen Mächten angelegt
haben.
Es war eine tragische Story.
Leute die spät eingestiegen waren, verloren teilweise ihr ganzes Erspartes.
Geld für die geplante Hochzeit.
Naja also ganz ehrlich, da musst du auch schon wirklich nicht ganz dicht im Kopf sein, wenn
du dann sagst, ach ja guck mal, ich hab keine Ahnung was da eigentlich gerade abgeht, aber
lass da mal kurz 350.000 Euro reinstecken, alles was ich hab, easy, also da verhält's
mir wirklich schwer zu sagen, also nicht zu sagen, selbst daran schuld.
Ihr Erbe verzockt oder verloren ihre Lebensversicherung und die Zweifel auf einen Neutenanstieg wurden
immer größer.
Schließt du deine Position und verhinderst, dass du noch mehr verlierst, verrätst aber
die Leute im Subreddit oder hältst du und nimmst damit den Kauf eventuell noch mehr
zu verlieren.
Und so vergeht eine Woche.
Ich kann übrigens unser Haus nicht mehr bezahlen, warum ey, ich hab GameStop gekauft.
Und noch eine Woche und der Kurs blieb weiterhin unten.
Und nachdem Reddit U seine Sammelklage gegen Robin Hood eingereicht haben, weil sie vermuteten,
dass HedgeFonds und Robin Hood unter eine Decke steckten, gab es am 28.
2.
eine Anhörung.
Auch Keith Gill war dabei, angeklagt von einem pleitegegangenen Investor, weil er angeblich
Leute dazu getrieben hat, mit ihm zusammen den Markt zu manipulieren.
Ob gemeinsame Sache gemacht wurde, weiß man bis heute nicht, aber Robin Hood und ein HedgeFond
namens Melvin Capital profitieren schon seit Jahren voneinander und haben zufällig einen
Tag vor dem Entfernen des Knopfes miteinander kommuniziert.
Jemand aus ihrem Unternehmen Robin Hood kontaktiert, um den Kauf von GameStop Aktien zu verhindern.
Gab es da jemanden?
Ja, ist, ich mein, wahrscheinlich stehen die, außerhalb der Kamera steht wahrscheinlich
grad schon einer mit der Sniper auf ihn gerichtet.
Sag jetzt nix Falsches, Alter!
Keith Gill sagt im Livestream, er hält die Aktie und glaubt immer noch an sie, während
im Hintergrund ein motivierendes Katzenbild und das berüchtigte rote Bandana zu sehen
ist.
Und das puzzelt er auch auf Reddit, er hält,
weiterhin trotz eines 15 Millionen Verlustes und somit entstand an diesem Tag eines der
meistgeleitetsten Reddit Posts of all time, der König davon hat gesprochen und seine
Armee stand hinter ihm, wenn er noch drin ist, sind sie es auch und diesmal hatten sie
Verstärkung, denn mittlerweile ging es um viel mehr als nur Geld, es ging um Gerechtigkeit
gegen die korrupte Börse und die Redditor waren diesmal vorbereitet, wie noch nie sich
Geld zurückzurollen.
Stonks!
Und die Leute schafften es mit geballter Kraft, den Preis nochmal auf 350 Dollar zu bringen.
Der Game Store war überall, Melvin Capital verlor Milliarden an Dollar und ging komplett
bankrott, dicht gefolgt von anderen Hedgefonds an der Börse, Reddit User schlugen die Investoren
mit ihren eigenen Waffen und das Mitleid für die dadurch pleitegegangenen Hedgefonds war
ziemlich gering auf Reddit.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Du bist ein Hedgefonds Manager.
Und ab hier fing der Preis über die nächsten Monate an zu schwanken und mit der Tendenz
bis heute zu fallen.
Denn viele Leute verkauften, bezahlten ihre Rechnungen damit oder mussten nie wieder arbeiten
gehen.
Viele dieser konnten plötzlich ihre medizinische Versorgung bezahlen und sich das erste Mal
im Leben Luxus geben.
Manche kauften sicher Traumauto oder nutzten ihr Geld für einen guten Zweck.
Ahja und sehr viele im Subreddit haben angefangen Gorillas zu adaptieren, weil Affe und so.
Stonks!
Doch wie immer bei der Börse gab es auch einige Leute, die sich in die Akte verliebt
haben, weil sie hofften, dass sie irgendwann nochmal ansteckt.
Denn so eine Trennung, eventuell ein Minus, kann für einige echt teuer werden und danach
haben Hedgefonds noch versucht, ein paar Redditor anzustellen.
Voraussetzung?
Hohes Reddit Karma, guter Memegeschmack, keine Ausbildung, ja gut und eine riesige Harambe
Statue wurde in der Wallstreet aufgestellt, sinnbildlich für den Kampf der kleinen Redditor
gegen die Großen und das Tor.
Das ist doch fake, oder?
Denn so eine Trennung, ja und danach haben Hedgefonds noch versucht, ein paar Redditor
anzustellen.
Voraussetzung?
Hohes Reddit Karma, guter Memegeschmack, keine Ausbildung, ja gut und eine riesige...
Das ist doch fake, oder?
Oder steht da wirklich eine Harambe Statue jetzt?
Der Harambe Statue wurde in der Wallstreet aufgestellt, sinnbildlich für den Kampf der
kleinen Redditor gegen die Großen und das Tor.
Der immer noch Aktienhaltende Kiefgehl postete dann noch ein letztes Update und die Affenarmee
löste sich so langsam bis auf ein paar Verbleibende auf.
Achso, das ist in kurzer Zeit irgendwas aus Plastik oder so, okay.
Jetzt wissen wir auch Bescheid, was bei Gamestorm gelaufen ist.
Und ich mit meinen ETF Stonks, hä?
Hast du jetzt den Job in Würzburg und ein kurzfristiges Angebot?
Ich hab das in Frankfurt angenommen, nicht das in Würzburg.
Obwohl, es hat mir wirklich sehr leid getan dort abzusagen, muss ich wirklich sagen.
Ich wusste gar nicht, wie ich das denen am besten beibringe, aber was soll ich machen?
Das andere Angebot hat einfach zu viele Vorteile, es ist näher und es gibt viel mehr Kohle.
Was soll ich sagen, letztendlich gehe ich nicht nur just for fun arbeiten, sondern ich
will auch Geld verdienen.
Wie laufen die ETFs?
Naja, so, Semi, nice.
Ich sag das immer wieder, ich bin bestechlich, Leute, was das angeht, also wer noch Prime
Subs hat, kein Problem.
Nee, also ich mach da schon Abstriche, also ich würde mich durchaus auch für ein, also
wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen zwei Arbeitgebern und der eine bezahlt ein bisschen weniger,
aber dafür ist bei dem alles drumherum viel, viel besser und toller, dass ich Leute, mit
denen ich besser klarkomme, bessere Homeoffice regel, alles besser, dann würde ich mich
auch für den entscheiden, obwohl es unterm Strich weniger Geld gibt, aber die Frage stellt
sich diesmal nicht.
Die in Frankfurt haben wirklich guten Eindruck auf mich gemacht und die bezahlen so viel
mehr, dass ich da die Frage für mich gar nicht gestellt hat mehr.
Bestellung, danke, Mirksow, jetzt bist du in der Abo-Falle.
Du bist quasi in der Gruppe, danke für den Sub, Eisfreak, 31 Monate, du bist schon richtig
lange dabei, danke für die Subs, Max jetzt über 100k, ja, aber knapp, aber wirklich
knapp.
Aber es ist jetzt 6-stellig, allerdings wie gesagt vorne ist noch eine 1, so viel erzähl
ich euch, mehr sag ich erstmal nicht, weil ich keine Ahnung hab, wie das da, ob das
darf oder ob das gewollt, aber gut, dürfen darf man, rechtlich kann man da eh nix dagegen
machen, aber muss ja nicht sein, ne, auf 40 Stunden gerechnet, selbstverständlich, jaja,
auf 5 Tage gerechnet, ich rechne es ja immer auf 5 Tage, ich arbeite aber plus 80%.
Also ich arbeite nur 4 Tage, ja, also, natürlich, natürlich, musst ja auch in anderen Jobs
suchen, es werden gerade händering, überall Leute gesucht und wenn du Ahnung hast, dann
erfüllst du was, natürlich jährlich, nicht monatlich, ich meine ich hab keine Gamestop
Aktie, ne, selbstverständlich jährlich, ne, ich hab ja Urlaubszeiten, ne, ich hab
ja Urlaub seit November, also ich war wenig Urlaub jetzt im November, war es noch nie
hier, sieht so aus, ja, weil, ich hab ja Urlaub im Dezember, also ich bin eigentlich, ich
war erstaunlich wenig am Chillen in meinem Urlaub bis jetzt, ich hab auch wenig Streams
gemacht, das hat sich einfach nicht hingehauen und jetzt muss ich auch noch MMO Kreisel
machen nebenbei, also 7 Stunden am Tag, da ist auch keine Zeit, aber ich mach ein Video
zu meiner aktuellen Jobsituation, wenn ich unterschrieben hab und das unter Dach und
Fach ist, weil sonst sag ich ja was, was nicht stimmt und erzähl dich ein bisschen was drum
herum, wie gesagt, Namen werden nicht erwähnt, genaue, konkrete Zahlen, so werden auch nicht
erwähnt, aber was so gelaufen ist, machst du beruflich, da würde ich dir empfehlen,
guck dir mal bei mir auf YouTube auf dem Channel, da hab ich ganz viele Videos zu diesem Thema
schon gemacht, ja, zum Beispiel das da, das was mache ich auf der Arbeit und sowas oder
das da kannst du ja auch was mit Noel zusammen gemacht haben, gibt's ein paar Videos zu,
welches MMO Kreisel gegrindet, Dark Age of Camelot auf dem FreeShard, hier, Game von
2002, in 2022 einfach ein fucking 20 Jahre altes Game, man, aber es sind immerhin schon
1400 Leute auf dem Server, was um die Uhrzeit relativ viel ist, 1400 Leute auf dem Server,
Dark bestes MMO ever, wie viele Stunden hast du die Woche, ich hab vorhin ausgerechnet,
ich glaube ich hab im Durchschnitt jetzt auf die Tage, wo ich gespielt hab, im Durchschnitt
irgendwie sechseinhalb Stunden gespielt, manche Tage mal mehr, mal manche Tage weniger,
was ist ein Kreiselgrind, wie erkläre ich Chat, wie erkläre ich was ein Kreiselgrind
ist, entweder man weiß was ein Kreiselgrind ist oder man weiß nicht was ein Kreiselgrind
ist, 6,5 Stunden am Tag ungefähr, im Durchschnitt, gestern waren es 11 Stunden, welches MMO Dark
Age of Camelot auf dem FreeShard, also was ist ein Kreiselgrind, man grindet im Kreis,
man macht wiederholt, man macht wiederholt, man grindet, man macht wiederholt irgendwas,
zum Beispiel Monster Kill in einem MMO, das halt im gleichen Gebiet im Kreis, wobei das
auch ausgedehnt werden kann auf mehrere Gebiete, mit dem Griechen als Leader, ja der gibt's
immer noch, der ist immer noch am Rumflamen, der Grieche, ja der flamt immer noch rum,
der ist immer noch am Start und flamt immer noch, die Leute, wenn sie nicht drauf hören,
was er sagt, ja, ja wie gesagt, ich kann dir nur empfehlen, guck dich mal ein bisschen
um, guck dich mal ein bisschen um, du wirst aktuell an jeder Ecke was finden und da muss
halt passen, ein Kollege von mir hat sich auch beworben, der wurde richtig jebaited,
hör dich das mal an, und zwar, der hat sich beworben auf einer Stelle, die haben geschrieben,
in der Stellenanzeige, also ist jetzt nicht mich, ist jetzt nicht von mir, von jemand
bei mir auf der Arbeit, der sich auch gerade woanders bewirbt, also der hat sich auf eine
Stelle beworben, irgendwas Senior Customer, frag mich nicht, es war nicht First Level,
es war so, ich weiß gar nicht in welche Richtung, das war irgendwie, irgendwelches Support-Fälle,
nicht direkt mit Endkunden, sondern irgendwelche Support-Fälle optimiert bearbeitet, frag mich
nicht genau, als Senior Support, Happiness Specialist, frag mich nicht, wie das hieß,
beworben, das ist eigentlich auch ganz gut, weil der arbeitet bei uns auch im Support,
zumindest hat er sich beworben, und die hatten in der Stellenanzeige stehen, Gehaltsspanne,
was ich schon cool fand, dass es in der Stellenanzeige drin stand, zumindest hatten die wohl in
der Stellenanzeige drin stehen, Gehaltsspanne 95k bis 105k, so, Standart drinne, hat er
mir erzählt, dann hat er sich dort beworben, lief auch richtig gut, dann hat er zusammen
mit denen so ein paar Support-Fälle besprochen, so wie würden sie folgenden Fall bearbeiten
und sowas in der Richtung, waren sie auch alle von ihm begeistert und haben gesagt, jawohl,
sie schicken ihm jetzt ein Angebot, und jetzt kam der Chebat, jetzt kam der Chebat des
Jahres, sie haben ihm ein Angebot geschickt für 75k, und da meinte er, Moment, ihr habt
doch in eurem, wir haben die ganze Zeit doch von 95 bis 100k gesprochen, und sogar in eurer
Stellenanzeige stand fast drinne, und da meinten die Seriously drauf, als Begründung dafür,
ja, wir haben leider das Budget für eine Senior-Stelle nicht genehmigt bekommen, deswegen ist das
jetzt eine normale, was ein Beschiss, was ein Beschiss, du machst erst mal das komplette
Bewerbungsverfahren und so durch, in dem Glauben, es passt am Ende, was ein Beschiss, man, ich
frage mich, hat er, hat er gemacht, also er ist nicht aufgestanden und gegangen, er hat
gesagt, nee, kommt für ihn da nicht in Frage und fertig, was ein Beschiss, oder, musst
dir mal vorstellen, was erwarten die sich denn davon, denken die dann, die Leute sagen,
oh, da habe ich jetzt schon so viel Energie reingesteckt, ich gebe mich dann auch da mit,
mit, was erwarten, was denken die sich, und vor allem, wie planlos muss der Laden dann
intern sein, wenn sie eine Stelle ausschreiben, die noch gar nicht genehmigt ist und so was,
what, also da habe ich mir auch am Kopf gegriffen, als er mir das erzählte, da dachte mir, was
zum Teufel, was ist denn mit denen los, exakt für die, exakt gleiche Stelle, ja, richtig
spreehead, ja, ich frage mich, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das überhaupt zulässig
ist, also das war, da habe ich mir echt, also als er mir das erzählte, habe ich auch gedacht,
alter, die wollen einen wirklich, das ist ja schon fast Scam, und ob es wirklich überhaupt
zulässig ist, weiß ich gar nicht, das müsste man jetzt irgendwie mal fragen, der sich da
mit Job und Arbeitsrecht und so was auskennt, keine Ahnung, ob das überhaupt erlaubt ist,
das war richtig, war richtig beschiss, ne, es war noch nicht mal Headhunter-Scam, es
war direkt von der Firma selbst, musstest du Programmier oder Coding-Interfuse machen,
nein, musste ich bis jetzt noch nicht, aber ich habe mich auch noch nie als hauptberuflicher
Entwickler beworben, ihr wisst, dass ich gerne Sachen programmier und Sachen bastel und
Tools entwickle und sonst was, ich meine, ich habe nicht umsonst ein paar, wie viel hat
eigentlich der Fiat-Camp mittlerweile für Sterne, guck mal 38 Sterne, richtig stonks,
geht steil der Fiat-Camp auf GitHub, tja, ne, aber musste ich noch nicht machen, ich
musste mir allerdings schon die ein oder anderen Fragen stellen lassen, wie ich spezielle
Szenarien handeln würde, ja, z.B. wie ich Cloud-Kosten kontrollieren würde, so was
in der Richtung, ja, da kann man dann z.B. als Antwort geben, ja, muss man halt gucken,
was man für eine Plattform verwenden kann, Limits setzen kann, ansonsten kann man das
natürlich auch automatisch überwachen, man kann Trends sich angucken, aber Limits ist
natürlich das Beste, um auf jeden Fall sicher zu gehen, dass man nicht über Nacht 40.000
Euro für sinnlose Sachen ausgibt und man sollte nach Möglichkeit keine Cloud-Functions
verwenden, die sich gegenseitig aufrufen und das dann auch im Kreis, ich hatte nämlich
als, okay, was sagt Stripes hier, er hatte sich als Entwickler beworben und die Stelle
war Junior Backend, der mit 60 keine Anzeige angebunden wird, dann später, das ist natürlich
für die Nichte, ja, okay, wenn du damit zufrieden bist, ist ja okay, aber ich finde es immer,
also ich finde es schon ein bisschen stady, immer diese Sachen so anzupreisen und am Ende
zu sagen, ach nee, nee, haben wir uns vertan oder geht jetzt doch nicht, ah, das Budget
ist nicht da, dann frage ich mich halt immer, was intern da bei der Koordination falsch
läuft, wenn das denn wirklich stimmt, vielleicht ist es einfach auch vorsätzlicher Scam, dass
man Leute günstiger kriegt.
Also gerade mit Azure Functions oder AWS, wie heißt, Lambda heißt da, glaube ich, genau,
ganze Server, da kannst du ganz schnell extrem viel Geld loswerden, wenn man will, nee, was
heißt, wenn man will, auch wenn man nicht will.
Nee, wie gesagt, wenn du damit am Ende zufrieden bist, ist ja gut, ja, Junior zum Berufseinstieg
ist das schon alles okay, aber du lernst auch, also du lernst die ersten eins, zwei Jahre,
nicht jeder, aber ich gehe davon aus, wenn man sich auch wirklich dafür interessiert
und das nicht einfach nur macht, weil sonst nichts anderes gibt, die ersten eins, zwei,
drei Jahre so viel, dass sie einen dann auf jeden Fall aufstocken müssen, sonst bezahlen
die andere deutlich mehr.
Ja, Checker MK kenn ich, das war früher eine Nagios Fork, mittlerweile weiß ich gar nicht,
was da noch so geht.
Lange nicht, lange nichts mehr mit gemacht, letzter Zeit hauptsächlich Prometheus, Grafana
und ein bisschen Zabbix.
Ja, das sind so Sachen, die noch irgendwo okay sind, da muss es halt im Vorfeld wissen.
Leute, ich kann euch nur eins wie sagen, ich hab die Gehaltsberechnung bei meinem neuen
Arbeitgeber, wahrscheinlich neuen Arbeitgeber, nicht so ganz gecheckt, das mussten sie mir
30 Minuten lang erklären, wie sich da was errechnet, aus Grund und Bonus und Fest und
sonst was, aber ich glaub, jetzt hab ich's gecheckt, nice, nice, okay, dann skaliert
das wahrscheinlich deutlich besser als eine einzelne Zabbix Instanz, weil Zabbix skaliert
nicht so richtig gescheit.
Das skaliert nicht diagonal und wir wissen ja, die einzig wahre Skalierung ist diagonal,
weil dann hat man horizontal und vertikal gleich mit drinne und man muss nur einmal
skalieren.
Jetzt sind wir uns einig, oder?
70 Server, ordentlich.
Ja, nicht zwangsläufig, ich glaube, da ist auch vieles Motivation dabei, weil wenn du
zum Beispiel so ein bisschen, dass das ganze erfolgsabhängig ist, also wie gut geht's
der Firma, wie gut hast du deine eigenen Sachen gemacht, ist das sicherlich für viele Leute
ja durchaus auch Motivation zu sagen, okay, ich streng mich jetzt besonders an, finde
ich ja auch nichts Verwerfliches dran, kann man ja machen.
Sind 55k für Bachelor Informatik ein Berufsverfahren im DevOps Backend gut, also es klingt durchaus
in Ordnung ja, so als Berufseinsteiger ist das denke ich ganz okay, es kommt natürlich
immer auf die Region an, was man genau macht, wie viel Plan man hat und alles drumherum,
kann man so pauschal natürlich nicht sagen, aber klingt doch erstmal in Ordnung, natürlich
müssen sich die nächsten Jahre über muss ich dann ein bisschen was tun, ist ja klar,
aber zum Einstieg, also ich kann euch sagen, was ich zum Einstieg verdient hab, wollt ihr
es wissen und zwar, also Ausbildungsgehalt kann ich euch nicht mehr sagen, hab ich wirklich
keine Ahnung, aber ich kann euch sagen, was ich damals zum Einstieg verdient habe, beim
Internet Provider, wo ich nach der Ausbildung angefangen hab und ich hab 33.500 Euro im
Jahr verdient, das war aber 2010, also schon 12 Jahre her, nach der Ausbildung oder 2009
könnte es sogar gewesen, nee 2010 war das relativ sicher, da hab ich mit 33.500 angefangen
im Internet Provider, hab ich ein Jahr gemacht, dann bin ich gewechselt, für deutlich mehr,
ja, wie lang für Cuddy, Cuddy ist richtig poggers, ja, sofern man nix advancedes machen
muss, was manchmal ein bisschen schwierig ist, teilweise gar nicht geht, also für das
was es ist, ist Cuddy wirklich top, keine Ahnung, zur Softwareentwickler kann ich nix
sagen, klingt aber erstmal echt nicht übel, das Einstieg, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich,
ja, nice, so muss es sein, die müssen ja ordentlich, die müssen nochmal ein bisschen was rumkommen,
gerade in der heutigen Zeit, ich gehe stark davon aus, dass viele Unternehmen so günstig
wegkommen, weil die Leute so faul sind wie ich und sich nicht umschauen, obwohl sie eigentlich
wissen, dass es woanders zur Zeit richtig, richtig gut Kohle abzusahnen gibt, wer von
euch ist auch noch faul as fuck, seid mal ehrlich Leute, was heißt faul, faul ist das
falsche Wort, Gewohnheitstier mäßig, as fuck halt, ja, bei mir hat es jetzt erst gebraucht,
dass ich erstens eh schon ein paar Sachen habe, die mir beim aktuellen Arbeit geben
auf dem Keks gehen und die ganze hin und her was Homeoffice angeht, das ist das was mich
halt jetzt im Endeffekt dazu gebracht hat, wirklich mal mit einem was anderem umzugucken
und es hat sich auf mehreren Ebenen jetzt schon gelohnt, erstens ein bisschen die Erfahrung
wieder, was Bewerben Vorstellungsgespräche angeht und den neuen Job, den ich jetzt gefunden
habe, ist sowohl von dem was ich bisher gesehen habe, arbeitstechnisch sehr nice und bezahlungsmäßig
auch sehr nice, also insofern lohnt sich eigentlich fast immer.
Es ist ein bisschen Voraussetzung, das ist aber auch wichtig, dass IT Leute faul sind,
faul auf eine ganze gewisse Art und Weise, nämlich faul in der Form, dass man dadurch,
dass man faul ist und nicht eine Sache 3, 4, 5 mal machen will, sie ordentlich macht beziehungsweise
so durchdacht macht, dass sie nicht wieder kaputt geht, das heißt eine gewisse, sage
ich auch immer, eine gewisse Faulheit ist für Admins und Programmierer gar nicht verkehrt.
Der Lebenslauf wird den Marktdown geschrieben, ich habe den Lebenslauf tatsächlich nicht
den Marktdown geschrieben, weil ich den Lebenslauf mit einer Vorlage gebaut habe, meine Skill-List
habe ich aber in den Marktdown geschrieben.
Korrekt, so sieht es aus, effizient muss man sein, beziehungsweise das wichtigste ist,
durchdachte Lösungen sich überlegen, also Sachen die halt nicht morgen wieder kaputt
gehen, einfach nur, dass es schnell fertig ist, sondern irgendwas was effizient gemacht
ist, aber auch durchdacht genug, dass es eben halt nicht, wenn man hinguckt, gleich wieder
zusammenfällt.
Max hast du eigentlich ein Wiki, du meinst wo ich Zeug bei mir aufschreibe, ja ich habe
ein Doku-Wiki bei mir lokal, wobei das verwende ich eigentlich nicht mehr, ich glaube das
kann ja mal abscheiden, ich schreibe das einfach in Notizen auf und gut ist, weil das das
im Browser ist, ist gar nicht so wichtig, das jetzt in einem Notizprogramm habe oder
im Browser ist eigentlich zweithangig.
Wie gesagt genau, genau sage ich es dir nicht, aber nachdem mich der Chat ja vorhin schon
gelöstert hat, beim neuen Job ist es dann sechsstellig, aber genaues erzähle ich nicht,
muss ich erstmal abwarten.
Was, was, ja wie offen man da dort gegenüber ist, wenn man Sachen erzählt im Internet,
weiß ich ja noch nicht.
Ich meine, an sich ist es nichts Geheimes, es ist nichts Geheimes, rein rechtlich gesehen
darf einem das der Arbeitgeber auch gar nicht verbieten über Gehalt, Geld zu sprechen,
das ist, machen viele, sagen so wird nicht erzählt, darf man aber eigentlich nicht,
achso ich arbeite nur 80%, ja ja und mit 80% sind es keine 100k oder nicht über 100k,
ja, auf fünf Tage gerechnet, auf fünf Tage gerechnet, geschenke es ab, ja ich muss auch
gucken wo ich bleibe, Gasrechnung, Heizungsrechnung, 5000€ neuer Rechner, irgendwie muss ich das
ja auch alles bezahlen.
Weiß dein neuer Arbeitgeber, ja theoretisch wissen die das und ich hab's in meinem Lebenslauf
stehen, ich hab beim Lebenslauf stehen, dass ich nebenberuflich selbstständiger Webvideoproduzent
bin, ja so gut wie, ich hab den Vertrag, ich hab alles schon, ich hab bloß noch den Vertrag
noch nicht in der Post, du findest denke ich ne Ausbildung, also aktuell ist es im IT Sektor
wirklich gut, wie es in der Ausbildung aktuell aussieht, Ausbildungsplätze zu finden, weiß
ich nicht, hab ich mich aus offensichtlichen Gründen in letzter Zeit nicht mit beschäftigen
müssen, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es auch ausbildungstechnisch zur Zeit recht
gut ist, nice, ja das ist übrigens, weil die Frage öfters kommt, das ist Christmas
Nintendo Music, Happy Tunes for Holidays, Winter Songs, ja das ist tatsächlich die Frage,
also bei mir in der Ausbildung, also das Unternehmen wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht hab, das war
auch nicht normal, es gab nämlich an sich keine Ausbildung, die Ausbildung war, so du
bist jetzt Azubi bei uns, mach jetzt mal, und da hattest du die Chancen entweder lernst
du was und machst, oder du sitzt 3 Jahre rum und hast am Ende nichts gelernt, so ne wirkliche
Ausbildung gab es da nicht, ja, ähm nein, nein, nein, nein, kenne ich keins zu, du musst
aber mal Battleship, wenn du sowas suchst, guck mal in diese Liste, guck mal in diese
Liste rein, da sind immer ganz gut Self-hosted Projekte, also ohne Cloud drinnen, natürlich
ist es nicht top aktuell und manche Sachen fehlen auch, aber das ist schonmal nicht verkehrt,
Tipps fürs Bewerben, bin nach Ausbildung und 2 Jahre Berufsverfahren als Softwareentwickler
auch zu überlegen und das ist sehr gut, ok lass mal überlegen, Tipps sich zu bewerben,
ich meine ich hab jetzt absolut den easy Mode, ich kannte jemand, der mich quasi empfohlen
hat, das ist natürlich immer, aber aktuell muss man sich, also eine Sache muss man sich
vergegenwertigen, bevor man Bewerbungen schreibt, ist, dass gerade in der aktuellen Zeit im IT
Sektor, wo es ja nun wirklich ziemlich schwierig ist für die Unternehmen Leute zu bekommen,
vor allem noch schwieriger ist Leute auch mit Ahnung zu bekommen, die dann auch noch
zu dem passen, was sie suchen, dass ich in beide Richtungen beworben wird, also du musst
nicht ganz zu sehr Arsch kriechen, ja, also du musst dich bewerben, aber es muss dich
auch ansprechen, weil du hast genug Auswahl aktuell, das muss man sich erstmal bisschen
im Kopf rufen, also man soll sich nicht aufführen wie die Axt im Walde oder so, das meine ich
nicht, aber du musst jetzt nicht alles mitmachen, wenn da irgendwie einer von dir will, dass
du zusätzlich da noch Wochenend Schicht machst, zusätzlich Nacht Einsatz machst, zusätzlich
hier und jenes und das und das am besten auch kostenlos und ohne bezahlten Überstunden,
also nö, dann könnt ihr euch jemand anderes suchen, also du hast Auswahl, so und dann als
ok Tipps, was habe ich, habe ich überhaupt sinnvolle Tipps zum Bewerben, also meine Bewerbungserfahrung
sieht ja wirklich mau aus, ich habe eine Ausbildung gemacht, da habe ich mich beworben drauf,
mehr oder weniger gleich beim zweiten Anlauf, oder fast schon der erste Anlauf eigentlich,
die Ausbildungsstelle gekriegt, so, dann bin ich gewechselt, das ging auch, die kannte
ich schon, da musste ich auch nicht großartig schreiben, so das heißt, ich habe mich jetzt
seit über 10 Jahren zum ersten Mal richtig beworben und jetzt wo es geklappt hat auch
noch, also beides mal auf Empfehlung hin, von jemanden der schon dort arbeitet, also
ich glaube, so die richtigen Hardcore Tipps kann ich dir jetzt nicht geben, es gibt ein
paar Sachen, die mir aufgefallen sind, also das erste ist, guck dir immer, bevor du in
Vorstellungsgespräch gehst, guck dir immer an, deine eigene, also nimm es am besten
mit zum Spicken, ja, nimm deine eigene Bewerbung mit, deine eigene Skill-Liste, deinen eigenen
Lebenslauf, nimm den mit, oder wenn es Remote ist, machst dir auf, mach dir die Stellenanzeige
auf, weil die fragen dich dann manchmal auch Sachen, wo sie sich irgendwie auf die Stellenanzeige
beziehen und im ersten Bewerbungsgespräch hatte ich die Stellenanzeige nicht offen,
hat mich gefragt, ja, ich habe mir die Stellenanzeige sicherlich genau gelesen und da steht drin
und ich mir so, äh, was, keine Ahnung, was da drin steht jetzt aus dem Kopf, man, aber
ich hab da nebenbei auf, das war Remote, hab ich da nebenbei aufgemacht, also, ja, das
würde ich empfehlen, dass du dich da ordentlich darauf vorzubereiten und es kann tatsächlich
auch nicht schaden, mal den Wikipedia-Artikel des jeweiligen Arbeitgebers oder die Seite
von dem sich anzugucken, einfach mal so ungefähr in welche Richtung es geht, weil das, es
hilft einfach, ja, wenn die schreiben zum Beispiel auf ihrer Webseite, ja, sie benutzen
hauptsächlich Azure und Microsoft Cloud oder sie machen hauptsächlich, äh, Linux mit
denen und den Technologien, was auch immer, dann ist es nicht verkehrt, das immer mal
wieder anzumerken, dass man sich ja damit auch auskennt, so, auf der anderen Seite bewerben
die sich genauso bei dir, also die müssen dich natürlich auch von sich überzeugen,
gerade in der heutigen Zeit, wachsen die, wachsen die Bewerber ja auch nicht gerade
auf dem, auf dem Baum, oder ansonsten kann ich dir wahrscheinlich gar nicht allzu viel
raten, ehrlich gesagt, Github-Profil ist nicht verkehrt, gerade wenn du dich als Software-Entwickler
bewirbst, Github-Profil, als du eins hast, Github-Profil mit ein paar, mit ein paar Projekten
drauf, ich hab das hier beispielsweise auch angegeben, ich hab tatsächlich den Fiat-Champ
in meiner Bewerbung angegeben und das war auch Thema im Vorstellungsgespräch und zwar,
ähm, dass ich, dass ich hobbymäßig halt Heimautomatisierung bei mir daheim äh, ziemlich
übertrieben hab, ja. Ja, aber du hast ja die Abschlussprüfung gemacht als AE, oder? Fach-Informatiker
Einwohnerentwicklung. Du kannst es natürlich auch über irgendeine Vermittlerbude machen,
ja, keine Frage, also, also, wenn du den LinkedIn-Account machst, das ist wahrscheinlich der, der beste
Tipp tatsächlich, mach den LinkedIn-Account, schreib drauf, was du kannst und du kriegst
am Tag 450, äh, 420 Recruiter-Anfragen, die wahrscheinlich zu 90% missed sind, aber du
kriegst viele Anfragen. Also, ein anderer Kollege von mir, von dem ich weiß, dass der
sich auch gerade was sucht, ihr werdet euch fragen, es suchen aber verdammt viele, Max,
wo du aktuell arbeitest, einen neuen Job und ja, das ist richtig, ich weiß, von mindestens
sieben Leuten in der IT bei uns, von sieben Leuten, also, nur von denen, wo ich öfters
mit was zu tun hab, mindestens sieben Leute, die gerade sich einen neuen Job suchen. Ähm,
mach den LinkedIn-Profil, oder lass dir von irgendeinem Recruiter da was vermitteln, schadet
auf jeden Fall, nix anhören kann man sich das. Dein Vater ratet dir immer zu viel Arsch
zu kriechen, ich hasse Arschgegrieche. Ich krieche keinem in Arsch. Sowohl im praktischen
Sinne als auch im übertragenen Sinne nicht. Also, ich finde das unsinnig, weil, ganz im
Ernst, man muss ja nicht unfreundlich sein, ja, das heißt ja gar nicht. Also du, man muss
jetzt nicht, also, wenn man nett ist, beziehungsweise die Sachen ein bisschen, ähm, ja, freundlich
formuliert, das hat ja, das schadet ja wirklich keinem, ja. Also man muss ja nicht sagen,
das was ihr euch da immer ausdenkt ist totaler Scheiß, wie kann man nur so dumm sein, sowas
zu machen. Ja, das muss man vielleicht nicht so sagen. Aber man kann durchaus sagen, wenn
man das für bescheuert hält, aus Gründen A, B, C, kann man das ruhig sagen, warum
man das blödsinnig findet. Also man muss nicht immer nur, weil irgendwie einer gesagt
hat, ja, das ist jetzt so das Beste, auch da immer zustimmen. Und gerade das ist es meiner
Meinung nach auch, was Lösungen technisch besser werden lässt, wenn nicht alles unhinterfragt
umgesetzt wird, nur weil sich irgend einer das mal so ausgedacht hat. Sondern wenn man
feststellt, dass man da Sachen besser machen könnte oder vielleicht auch feststellt, das
kann so gar nicht funktionieren, dass man das sagt und wenn man das irgendwo nicht mehr
sagen kann, dann hat dieses Unternehmen wirkliche Probleme, was innovative Sachen angeht und
wahrscheinlich auch, ja, keine über längere Zeit, keine allzu gute Zukunft, weil sobald
du sowas nicht mehr ansprechen kannst, also Sachen die objektiv nicht gut sind, was übrigens
auch eine der Probleme ist, die ich dort habe, wo ich gerade aktuell arbeite, dann sieht
das nicht so gut aus. Also Krummgeschleime finde ich nicht gut. Man kann nett sein zu
den Leuten, das finde ich immer. Ich finde es wichtig, dass das Arbeitsklima gut ist
und die Leute permanent anzukacken ist sicherlich nicht the way, aber wenn was nicht gut ist,
kann man das schon sagen.
Würdest du sagen, man hat in der IT noch Zukunftschancen? Ja klar, wenn da, wo sonst? Nein, das ist
Blödsinn, das wird nicht passieren. Das wird nicht passieren. Es wird in Zukunft
eher noch schlimmer werden, weil es gibt einen Grund, warum ich glaube, dass es sogar noch
zunehmen wird, das ist folgendes. Es gibt einige Branchen, ja, denkt mal an Bergarbeiter
oder sowas, die braucht man jetzt gar nicht mehr, aber denkt mal beispielsweise an irgendwelche
Fließbandtätigkeiten oder in der Fabrik. Es gibt viele Arbeiten, die wurden bis vor
kurzem oder werden immer noch von Hand oder von, sag mal, zumindest Leuten, die ja mit
manuellen Handgriffen da involviert sind, ausgeführt. Diese Jobs werden in den nächsten
Jahren auf jeden Fall immer weniger werden und es wird zwar nicht im gleichen Maße,
aber ich muss das anders sagen, aktuell stehen am Fließband 10 Leute und stellen irgendwas
her. Das wird jetzt automatisiert, dann brauchst du nicht 10 Programmierer und Wartungsleute
für die Automatisierung, aber du brauchst vielleicht 2. Es fallen 10 Leute weg am Fließband,
aber du brauchst neue Leute zum Programmieren, zum Entwickeln, zum Warten, also du brauchst
neue Techniker oder IT-Leute. Also sagen wir mal 10 fallen weg, 2 neue IT-Jobs gibts. Das
heißt, es gibt zwar insgesamt weniger Jobs vielleicht in dieser Branche, aber es gibt
insgesamt mehr IT-Jobs und das wird in nächster Zeit noch deutlich zunehmen. An vielen Stellen
sind wir teilweise in Deutschland ein bisschen rückständig, also sprich, da werden noch
Faxe verschickt, allein, dass es sicher zugestellt ist und solche Sachen. In dem Sektor werden
auch mehr IT-Jobs entstehen und gebraucht werden, viele werden jetzt schon gebraucht,
können nicht besetzt werden. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass es in Zukunft sogar noch schlimmer
wird. Klar, es werden auch Leute ausgebildet, es gibt auch Leute, die Informatik studieren,
es gibt schon neue Leute, die da jetzt reinkommen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es das Verhältnis
überschreitet von, es kommen immer mehr Leute nach zu dem, was neue Stellen gebraucht werden.
Also ich glaube, in nächster Zeit wirst du überhaupt keine Probleme haben, in der IT-Leute
Jobs zu finden, die werden eher Probleme haben, Leute zu finden und die Unternehmen, die immer
noch der Meinung sind, sie sind irgendwie die 0815 5-Mann-Klitsche um die Ecke, sind
aber das nächste Google, auch mit ihren Vorstellungen und leider nicht bei den Gehaltsvorstellungen,
die werden schlicht und greifend keine Leute finden. Wenn es so schlimm ist, wieso zahlen
die Unternehmen so schlecht, tja, die kriegen auch keine Leute, die schlecht bezahlen. Das
einzige, warum die schlecht sich erlauben können, schlecht zu bezahlen ist, weil Leute
dort arbeiten, die so faul sind wie ich und das mitmachen, was ja auch nix verwerfliches
ist, also Geld ist ja auch nicht alles, also wenn man da super zufrieden mit ist und prinzipiell
mit der Bezahlung gut über die Runden kommt, spricht er da eigentlich auch nix dagegen,
kann man ja machen, aber woanders wirst du wahrscheinlich mehr Geld kriegen. Ich bin
auch zu faul, macht ihr keine Gedanken drüber, wir sind alle zu faul, ich hab gerade im Chat
gefragt, wir sind alle zu faul, ich auch, bei mir war jetzt aber der Punkt überschritten,
als sie bei mir wieder gesagt haben, Leute sollen alle ins Büro kommen, wo ich gesagt
hab, was, man hat die letzten zweieinhalb Jahre gesehen, wie gut das funktioniert, das ist
für alle Beteiligten besser, was ist mit euch los. Die können sich das eben nicht erlauben,
schlecht zu bezahlen, weil die, die schlecht bezahlen plus auch nix zu bieten haben, bekommen
schlicht und ergreifend keine Leute. Ja, muss gerade mal den Chat aufholen.
Was ist denn ein Gesellenbrief als Anwendungsentwickler? Ich kenne nur die IHK-Abschussprüfung. Berufsstuhl
ist für'n Arsch, ja? Ja, das ist, das ist halt dazu wie aber oft so. Das, das würde
ich aber gar nicht so sehen, dass du als billige Arbeitskraft benutzt wirst, das wirst du, das
werden alle Azubis letztendlich. In meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb war es auch so, wir hatten
keine Ausbildung, entweder hat man was gemacht und dann was gelernt oder nicht, aber meistens
hast du in dem Fall, das ist ein Gesellenbrief, okay, meistens hast du in dem Fall die Chance,
wenn du als billige Arbeitskraft benutzt wirst, dass du wirklich was lernen musst, also entweder
machst du halt einfach nichts, weil du nichts lernst und hast zwar nach 3 Jahren die Ausbildung
fertig, aber hast keine Ahnung oder du lernst wirklich was, weil du selbst was machen musst
und danach machst du dich einfach vom Acker. Du musst die Ausbildung benutzen, wirklich
Ahnung zu haben danach, weil ganz im Ernst, der Ausbildungstattle am Ende, alleine bringt
der dir auch nicht viel. Du musst schon ein bisschen Ahnung haben. Also du kannst jetzt
nicht sagen, Leute, ich habe eine Fachinformatiker-Ausbildung fertig, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, also wenn
die beispielsweise jemand suchen, wir sagen jetzt Anwendungsentwicklung, wenn die beispielsweise
jemand suchen, der sich mit Java, Java ist beliebt im Enterprise Umfeld, der sich mit
Java auskennt und dort mit Spring Boot und Web Services und hast du nicht gesehen und
du sagst, ja aber ich kann bloß in Windows 3 Assistenten auf Next Next OK klicken, dann
bringt das nichts. Also musst in deiner Ausbildung was lernen und da gibt es eigentlich nichts
besseres dazu, wie wenn du wirklich selbst was machen musst. Und wenn der Laden kacke
ist, dann haust du danach einfach ab. Und ob du überqualifiziert bist, das kannst du,
weiß ich nicht, meinst du damit, du kennst dich schon zu gut aus. Also ich habe viele
Azubis erlebt, die der Meinung waren, sie haben den super krassen Plan und sie haben
dann versucht beispielsweise im Rechenzentrum einen eigenen Filesharing-Dienst zu hosten
und sowas. Also mir sind Azubis prinzipiell suspekt, die selbst denken, sie haben den
allerkrassensten Plan. Es geht halt auch im Job oftmals nicht rein um die Technik, sondern
dass man eben lernt, wie man diese Technik im Business Enterprise Umfeld anwendet. Weil
es ist ein Unterschied, ob du beispielsweise Anwendungen daheim als Hobby Just For Fun
mit dir alleine entwickelst, die am Endeffekt auch keiner wirklich benutzen wird und du
alleine dran bauen kannst, wie du willst. Oder ob du das im Team mit 15 Leuten machst
und im Endeffekt gehen Millionen verloren, wenn es mal irgendwelche Probleme gibt. Die
Sprache ist die gleiche, die Framework sind die gleichen, im Prinzip das was du machst
ist das gleiche. Aber so dieser Enterprise Business Faktor dabei, der ist nicht zu unterschätzen
und das lernt man tatsächlich nur mit Erfahrung und halt auch nur auf der Arbeit. Das kannst
du nicht alleine lernen. Das ist jetzt nicht nur im Anwendungsentwicklungsektor so ist,
wenn du Systeme administrierst, also wenn du System Integrator bist, also quasi, die meisten
Leute sind ja sowas wie Server Admin dann, da ist das ähnlich. Es ist ein Unterschied,
ob du bei Hetzner drei Kisten bei dir hast, daheim und da machst du ein bisschen was drauf,
oder ob du 5000 Linux Server hast, worauf wichtige Systeme laufen, wo dann im Endeffekt die Abrechnung
nicht mehr funktioniert für euren Außendienst oder wo dann vielleicht sogar das ganze Trading
nicht mehr funktioniert oder was in der Richtung. Da hängt halt ein bisschen was anderes dran
wie bei deinen drei Hetznerservern und das lernt man halt daheim nicht, das lernt man
tatsächlich nur da im Business Umfeld, zumal es oftmals auch die Zusammenarbeit ist, die
sich schwierig gestaltet. Du musst dann gucken, irgendjemand programmiert die Anwendung, irgendjemand
ist für Wartungsarbeiten, Change Koordination zuständig, du musst auf dem Server XY machen,
das lernt man halt nur im Business Umfeld und das ist wichtig, dass man das auch während der
Ausbildung lernt, weil Technik auf der einen Seite schön und gut, aber du musst doch wissen,
wie du die Technik im Business Umfeld anwendest. Das hört sich jetzt ein bisschen abstrakt an,
aber ich glaube man weiß, wie ich das meine, aber das wichtigste ist natürlich immer noch,
dass man von der Technik Ahnung hat, da gibt es nichts, da muss man einen Plan haben.
Gibt es bestimmte Branchen, in denen die IT-Aufgaben besonders spannend sind,
IT-Aufgaben können überall spannend sein, kommt auf das Unternehmen an und selbst wenn
es auf den ersten Blick wie der langweiligste Laden aller Zeiten aussieht, können die Aufgaben
trotzdem spannend sein. Hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen was von deinen Kenntnissen,
deinen Vorlieben ab und was am Ende ist, es kann überall sein.
Was hältst du von einer Karriere als IT-Consultant?
Nix. Was hältst du von Konuno?
Finde ich nicht verkehrt. Ja finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Guck ich auch immer. Guck ich auch immer.
Wobei manche, wobei manche Wertungen, da wirklich, die schreien schon fake, ja.
Wenn ich bei Konuno manche Bewertungen lese, denke ich mir auch, was zum Teufel ist da los.
Das ist halt so richtig, so richtig in personaler Deutsch geschrieben, schon wo du dir denkst,
da hat sich einer von der Personalabteilung hingesetzt und sich selbst eine gute
Bewertung verpasst, so nach dem Motto. Wisst ihr, wenn Bewertungen geschrieben sind
auf die gleiche Art und Weise, wie Stellenanzeigen geschrieben sind,
so, dann denkst du schon, da kann doch was nicht stimmen.
Also, was sich ein Top-Unternehmen mit einem jungen, dynamischen, motiviertem Team,
hier erreicht man noch gemeinsam seine Ziele, ein ganz tolles Unternehmen.
Und wenn du solche, wenn du solche Bewertungen siehst bei Konuno,
da weißt du schon immer, Moment, da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Da stimmt irgendwas nicht, dass es irgendein Typ, der dort arbeitet
und wahrscheinlich sich selbst fünf Steine geben will.
Aber finde ich, die Seite an sich finde ich sehr praktisch.
Also, die Sache ist halt die, das ist, es geht dir, dann geht es dir
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen wie bei mir. Ich war eigentlich zufrieden mit dem,
was ich verdiene, ja, darum ging es mir gar nicht.
Ich habe aber auch gesagt, hey, wenn man sich mal umschaut,
das habe ich ja schon die letzten paar Jahre über gemacht,
wenn man sich umschaut, woanders gibt es eine ganze Ecke mehr.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie doppelt so viel oder so,
aber es ist schon ein bisschen mehr. Und es gibt ja noch ein paar andere
Faktoren, die mich da gestört haben. Und ich habe das jetzt,
ich habe das total oft angesprochen bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Also, dass ich mit den Homeoffice-Regelungen nicht zufrieden bin,
wie es mit Geld aussieht, mit Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten,
es hat sich nie was getan. Ja, Arbeitskollege von mir,
der übrigens, by the way, der, der sich jetzt mit mir dort auch
beworben hat bei der neuen Stelle, dem haben sie zweimal,
muss man sich mal vorstellen, der ist aber glaube ich auch schon
acht Jahre oder so da gewesen bei dem Laden. Und sie haben,
das muss man sich wirklich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, ja.
Er hat auch schon mehrfach dort Sachen angesprochen,
die nicht gut funktionieren und man hat ihm versprochen,
dass man sich den Problem annehmen wird und auch schaut,
was Schulungen angeht, was Weiterentwicklungsmöglichkeiten
angeht, was Gehalt angeht und solche Geschichten.
Und da hat man mit ihm einen 2,5-Jahres-Plan war das,
glaube ich, gemacht. So, die haben mit ihm quasi was ausgehandelt
über 2,5 Jahre. Und jetzt ratet mal, was passiert ist davon.
Okay, ich muss euch anders fragen. Ratet mal von diesen 4,
5 Punkten, die in diesem Plan drinnen standen,
wovon ihm persönlich eigentlich nur 2 Punkte wirklich wichtig waren.
Wie viel der 2 Punkte oder ist eines dieser Punkte
erfüllt worden nach 2,5 Jahren? Nichts, korrekt.
So, daraufhin ist nichts. Also, bei den anderen Punkten ist was
passiert, aber das waren so beiläufige Sachen, ja.
Also, bei den wichtigen 2 Punkten, um die es ihm ging,
ist nichts passiert. Dann hat er sich darauf eingelassen,
dass sie noch mal einen 2-Jahres-Plan gemacht haben.
Danach noch mal. Aber gleich kommt der Hit.
Da lacht er euch kaputt. So, sie haben noch mal
einen 2-Jahres-Plan mit ihm gemacht. Und davon wurde ein Punkt
nach diesen 2 Jahren, ein Punkt wurde so, na ja, halbherzig erledigt.
Und zwar ging es darum, er hat sich immer drüber beschwert,
ist übrigens jemand, der im Support arbeitet.
Und er hat sich immer drüber beschwert, dass sie im Endeffekt
von so vielen Technologien Ahnung haben müssen,
zumindest überblicksweise Ahnung haben müssen,
dass mit Support, meine ich nicht Endkunden-Support,
sondern eigentlich ist es eher so Eskalation und Entstörung.
Also sprich, die überwachen unsere Systeme 24-7,
müssen, wenn es Fehler gibt, einschätzen,
wie kritisch ist das Ganze und dann Entstörung in die Wege leiten
und Leute anrufen nachts und das koordinieren.
Also das ist tatsächlich nicht ganz so ohne.
Es ist nicht, hallo, hier ist der Vodafone-Support oder so was.
Und der hat sich schon jahrelang drüber beschwert,
dass sie so viele verschiedene Technologien hier im Einsatz haben
und die Firma es einfach nicht auf die Reihe bekommt,
dass man halbwegs Schritt hält bei ihrer Ahnung im Endeffekt.
Also z.B., dass neue Technologien eingesetzt werden,
aber die sind dann immer live,
obwohl noch nie irgendjemand ihnen was erklärt hat dazu.
Und z.B. auch was Cloud-Sachen angeht,
hat er schon seit Jahren erzählt,
lasst uns doch mal wenigstens für alle Leute,
dass sie die Basic-Ager-Schulung machen,
dass die Leute zumindest so die Grundlagen einschätzen können.
Das hat die Firma alles nicht auf die Reihe bekommen, richtig?
Und man hat das jetzt halbherzig gelöst, diesen Punkt.
Also es ging ihm noch nicht mal wirklich um mehr Geld oder so was,
sondern einfach nur, dass er seine Arbeit tatsächlich besser machen kann.
So, und wisst ihr, wie sie das jetzt gelöst haben?
Es gibt jetzt ein Seminarbuchungssystem,
da kann man sich für Schulungen eintragen.
Wann die Schulungen stattfinden, steht komplett in den Sternen.
Geile Lösung, super.
So, und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Das ist übrigens jemand, mit dem ich mich super verstehe
und wo es wirklich schade gewesen wäre,
wenn wir nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten können.
Und das ist derjenige, mit dem ich mich zusammen beworben habe,
dort bei der anderen Firma jetzt.
Und wir gehen beide jetzt quasi zu einer anderen Firma.
Und wisst ihr, was der Hit ist?
Jetzt, wo der gesagt hat, Jungs, ich mache mich vom Acker,
und ich habe ja auch gesagt, Jungs, ich mache mich dann demnächst vom Acker.
Jetzt, wo er gesagt hat, ich mache mich vom Acker,
kamen sie um die Ecke, es ist kein Spaß, haben sie zu ihm gesagt,
wir arbeiten gerade an einem neuen 3,5 Jahre Plan.
3,5 Jahre Plan.
Also, man hat ja schon gesehen, wie gut die letzten Pläne funktioniert haben.
Und jetzt 3,5 Jahre Plan, Alter.
Was zum Teufel, man.
Wir sind sich da management-technisch gar nichts zu schade.
Also, keine Ahnung, wie ich jetzt da drauf gekommen bin, aber ja.
Mit dem fange ich demnächst zusammen bei dem neuen Unternehmen an.
Ich bin echt froh, mit dem verstehe ich mich super.
Und wenn ich mit dem Sachen zusammen mache,
kommen auch immer gutes Zeug bei raus.
Ja, genau, jetzt weiß ich, wie ich drauf gekommen bin, genau.
Ja, das ist bei uns auch, bei uns werden die Leute auch immer hingehalten.
Du musst letztendlich irgendwann sagen, Alter, ist mir zu wenig
oder manche andere Sachen gehen mir auf den Keks.
Ich suche mir was Neues und entweder was sein kann,
dass sie dir dann ein ordentliches Gegenangebot machen.
Wobei man dann halt immer sagen muss, die Probleme,
die dir auf den Keks gegangen sind,
wenn sie nicht nur finanzieller Natur waren, sind ja immer noch da.
Deswegen ist das mit Gegenangebot annehmen immer so ein bisschen fraglich.
Aber natürlich, die machen das auf Sparflamme,
wenn die denken, die Leute hauen dich ab.
Und in der aktuellen Zeit ist es so, gerade wenn du Ahnung hast,
du hast wirklich viele Möglichkeiten, was IT angeht.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß von sieben Leuten dort,
wo ich aktuell arbeite, dass sie sich was Neues suchen.
Hast du schon mal was vom Microsoft WoW Programm gehört?
Was ist denn das Microsoft WoW Programm?
WoW. Workforce of the Future.
Nee, kenn ich nicht.
Der Name ist schon ein bisschen cringe, oder?
Workforce of the Future.
Upskilling. Upskilling heißt Umschulung, oder?
Ist Upskilling die schöne Variante von Umschulung?
Also quasi man nimmt jemand und bringt ihm was bei,
was jetzt gerade sehr gefragt ist.
Jaja, ist sowas in der Richtung.
Keine Ahnung, hab ich schon nie was von gehört.
Ja, warum die keinen bekommen, ja genau.
Du denkst dir schon das Richtige.
Warum die Leute niemand bekommen,
warum die Unternehmen keine bekommen, ist doch ganz einfach.
Es ist meistens eine Kombination, aber ist doch ganz einfach.
Sie bezahlen nicht genug in Kombination mit,
die Stelle ist nicht interessant genug,
beziehungsweise nicht attraktiv genug.
Also irgendwas muss ja sein.
Meistens ist es halt eine Kombination daraus.
Ich meine, die Stelle kann sich nach super nervig anhören,
aber sie bezahlen halt mega krass.
Dann sagen trotzdem Leute, ja egal, gibt wenigstens Kohle.
Oder die Stelle hört sich gut an, so geil,
dass die Bezahlung nicht so gut sein muss.
Oder aber, so wie sie Unternehmen machen,
die auch Leute kriegen, die Stelle hört sich gut an
und die Bezahlung ist gut.
Und dann sagen die Leute, ja, dann gehe ich doch dahin,
wobei das zusammenkommt.
Muss ich im Chat fragen, hatten wir vorhin ein paar Leute?
Kann ich so nicht, nicht, weiß ich nicht.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich blödsinnig.
Also wenn man das wirklich so gesagt hat, ist natürlich bescheuert.
Man kann sich nicht von einem Azubi erwarten, dass der super krass ist.
Also das Einzige, wisst ihr was das Einzige ist,
was ich von einem Azubi erwarte?
Das Einzige, ich erwarte nicht, dass er super krasse Vorkenntnisse hat
oder dass der schon alles kann in der Ausbildung.
Ratet mal, was ist denn das Einzige,
was ich wirklich von einem Azubi erwarte?
Mal gucken, ob der Chat bei mir anfangen könnte,
dass er Bock hat.
Richtig, das ist tatsächlich, im Prinzip, ihr habt im Prinzip das alles,
ihr habt alles das gleiche,
ihr habt alle mit unterschiedlichen Worten das gleiche geschrieben.
Dass er Bock hat, das ist tatsächlich die beste Beschreibung dafür, ja,
dass er Bock hat.
Das ist das Einzige, was ich vom Azubi erwarte, dass er Bock hat.
Der Azubi muss nichts großartig können,
vorher muss er Bock haben bzw. auch in der Lage sein,
das zu lernen in seiner Ausbildung
und dazu muss er Bock haben.
Ja, gut, das ist halt Berufsschule,
Berufsschule bringt nichts,
Berufsschule ist komplett für'n Arsch.
Also der, wie heißt das auch, der Moment,
der mir am meisten in der Berufsschule hängen geblieben ist,
ist der, als mein Wirtschaftslehrer über mein DS-Ladekabel gestolpert ist.
Das ist der Moment, der mir am meisten in der,
das sagt schon alles, oder?
Wenn der Moment, der dir am meisten in der Berufsschule hängen geblieben ist,
dass das Stolpern des Lehrers über dein DS-Ladekabel ist,
am meisten Bescheid.
Ja, Mario Kart Multiplayer gespielt auf dem DS in der Berufsschule.
Ich musste halt aufladen.
Ja, Bundesland-Branche ist tatsächlich sehr entscheidend.
Also ich kann euch sagen, dass beispielsweise so Versicherung
und Bankensektor in Frankfurt natürlich recht lukraktiv ist,
aber gibt's bestimmt auch noch mehr.
Übrigens, eine Sache, wisst ihr, was ich gelernt habe
in meinem Vorstellungsgespräch?
Wisst ihr, zu welcher Gruppe ich gezählt wurde?
Und zwar, ich wurde weder als Zoomer noch als Boomer gezählt,
sondern als, haltet euch fest, Best-Ager wurde ich dazu gezählt.
Ich kannte dieses Wort bisher noch gar nicht,
aber jetzt weiß ich, Best-Ager.
Also im Prinzip heißt das unterm Strich,
ich bin noch nicht so alt, dass ich bald in Rente gehe,
aber ich hab schon Ahnung von dem, was ich mache.
Also im Nachhinein ist es ja gar nicht verkehrt, ja.
Ich bin jetzt 38, bin 1984 geboren.
Pog-Ager, genau, war nicht nice, hab ich noch nie gehört,
den Begriff war.
Wie gesagt, Abstand, ja, nix.
Es gibt ja noch mehrere Zwischbringungen.
Junior ist halt quasi ein Einsteiger.
Dann gibt es noch den gleichen Beruf ohne Senior oder Junior davor
und dann gibt es den Beruf oder die Stelle mit Senior davor.
Also du kannst quasi, sagen wir mal, sowas wie Junior Softwareentwickler sein
oder du kannst Softwareentwickler sein oder du kannst Senior Softwareentwickler sein
oder du kannst Architekt oder Expert oder sowas noch sein,
je nachdem, wie das dann noch gesteigert werden kann.
Oder Professional, ja, das machen alle so ein bisschen anders.
Wisst ihr, was für mich auch tatsächlich ein Faktor ist, den ich beim Senior sehen
würde?
Dass ein Senior in der Lage ist, es teamübergreifend gut zu verkaufen
oder besser gesagt, sich auch teamübergreifend einbringen zu können.
Zum Beispiel, wenn irgendeine neue Technologie X, Y gebraucht wird
und es gibt irgendwelche Diskussionen drüber, die Anwendungsentwicklung hätte gerne
Produkt A, weil es eine tolle API hatten, easy und super Java und so.
Ja, dann hätte beispielsweise die BWL Leute hätten gern das,
weil dieses eine Feature kann, Serveradministration hätte gerne X, Y,
weil das besser ist, dass man sich bei sowas sinnvoll beteiligt.
Ich finde, das ist auch was, was ich eher bei einem Senior sehen würde.
Wobei man sagen muss, ich würde es ja nicht mal zwangsläufig
rein als Kommunikationsskill sehen, weil ihr kennt mich, ich bin da jetzt auch was
zwischenmenschliche Sachen angeht, vielleicht nicht unbedingt der allerbeste immer,
aber auf technischer Ebene kann ich glaube ich sowas mittlerweile ganz gut.
Ich präsentiere beispielsweise mittlerweile Sachen auch gerne, habe ich euch ja schon
ein paar mal erzählt.
Das habe ich früher total ungern gemacht, aber mittlerweile stelle ich mich tatsächlich
gerne hin und präsentiere mal was.
Das ist wirklich was, was ich auch eher bei einer Senior Position sehen würde,
dass man halt auch die Sachen irgendwo gut verkaufen kann.
Es war unabhängig von technischer Ahnung und sowas, ja.
Wärst du grundsätzlich bereit nebenberuflich jemanden auszubilden?
Das kann ich, das darf ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht und würde ich auch nicht machen,
wie soll ich das nebenbei machen?
Würdest du sagen, es lohnt sich auf Full-Stack-Stellen zu bewerten, wenn man als Backend-Arbeitstechniker
nichts mit TypeScript...kommt drauf an, was die unter Full-Stack verstehen.
Mein Full-Stack heißt ja nicht zwangsläufig, zwar meistens heißt es das, aber es heißt
ja nicht zwangsläufig Backend-Server-Anwendung und Web-Frontend zu 95% schon, aber das muss
es ja nicht zwangsläufig heißen.
Es kommt halt drauf an, was die machen und ob die TypeScript verwenden, ist halt die Frage.
Also ob du dich auf eine Full-Stack-Stelle bewerben solltest, hängt davon ab, was in
der Full-Stack-Stelle drin steht und ob du denkst, das passt oder nicht.
Also wenn die jetzt beispielsweise schreiben, dass du als Full-Stack Ahnung von Postgres
haben sollst, Ahnung von ASP.NET Core haben sollst und Angular beherrschen sollst, was,
naja, kann man sich auch zwar schon überschreien, und du allerdings nur Laravel und...keine
Ahnung, SQLite kannst, dann vielleicht eher nicht, es muss halt irgendwo passen, letztendlich
ganz im Ernst, neue Technologien sind schnell gelernt, wenn man sich mit ähnlichen Sachen
auskennt, also eine Sache, die viel wichtiger ist aus meiner Sicht, ist, dass die Leute
gut ins Team passen, die man sich anlacht, auch wenn die vielleicht nicht alle Sachen
gut abdecken.
Aber teaminterne Stimmung und dass die Leute miteinander klarkommen, ist ein nicht zu unterschätzender
Faktor.
Also ich bin glücklicherweise nicht an dieser Position, dass ich das entscheiden müsste,
ich würde lieber jemanden einstellen, der gut in mein Team passt, als jemand, der vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr Ahnung von den Technologien hat, die wir verwenden, aber wo ich schon
gleich merke, das ist ein Depp und er geht mir jetzt schon auf den Keks, bzw. würde nicht
mit meinen Leuten klarkommen.
Weil in Technologien eingearbeitet bist du schnell, stell dir mal vor, jemand hat in
seiner, bleiben wir mal bei irgendeiner Frontend-Geschichte, stell dir mal vor, irgendjemand sagt, er hat
Erfahrung mit C-Sharp, ASP.NET Core und Vue.js und du suchst aber jemand, der Spring Boot,
Java und ein bisschen Frontend mit React macht, ja, das kriegt er hin, kannst du von ausgehen,
nicht am ersten Tag, aber das kriegt er in relativ kurzer Zeit hin, gerade wenn er sich
gut ins Team einfügt und die Leute sich gut verstehen, dann lernt er das auch schneller,
das kriegt er hin, da will ich mir keine Gedanken machen, man kann es sich am ersten
Tag machen, aber selbst wenn, und das ist auch ein unterschätzter Faktor, selbst wenn
du jemanden hast, der perfekt passt von den Technologien, stell dir mal vor, irgendjemand
verwendet Ubuntu als, du suchst einen Server Admin, ihr verwendet Ubuntu mit Nginx drauf
als Web Server, Postgres als Datenbank, so eine klassische, klassische Geschichte, ja,
und du findest jemand, der in der Stellenanzeige exakt diese Sachen drinstehen hat, auch schon
super Erfahrung, das heißt noch lange nicht, dass der eins zu eins am ersten Tag volle
Pulle alles machen kann, weil, nur weil du von den Technologien Ahnung hast, heißt
es ja noch lange nicht, dass du weißt, wie es in dem jeweiligen Unternehmen benutzt wird.
Nginx ist ein Web Server, ja, schön und gut, aber was machen die genau damit, was für
Anwendungen laufen denn dahinter, was haben die, machen die letzte Encrypt Zertifikate,
was brauchen die für eine Config, was läuft für ein Betriebssystem unten drunter, wie
läuft das Change Management im jeweiligen Unternehmen und sowas, das weißt du alles
nicht, das heißt, selbst wenn du Ahnung von der Technologie hast, kannst du trotzdem nicht
am ersten Tag da was machen, 100%ig, also wenn so prinzipiell das passt, kannst du dich
da durchaus drauf bewerben, so pauschal kann man das natürlich nicht sagen.
Das stimmt, ja, sowas in der Richtung ist das genau.
Was ist aus dem Monitoring System geworden, aus welchem?
Ist witzigerweise dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, relativ ähnlich, den rennen die Leute gerade
weg und externe kosten irgendwie das, das, keine Ahnung, fünf bis zehnfache, ich verstehe
die Logik ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so ganz, zumal schon total oft das Problem gab, dass
externe richtige Know-How-Träger waren und die sind halt einfach abgehauen, weil es halt
externe sind, keine Ahnung, die Logik verstehe ich nicht, da muss man wahrscheinlich HiIQ
L-Management Ausbildung haben, um das zu verstehen.
Ja, das kann die nicht ernst gemeint haben, so blöd ist keiner.
Hast du eigentlich ein Anschreiben machen müssen, nein, in beiden Fällen nicht, in
allen drei Fällen nicht, kein Anschreiben.
Du bist genau das, du bist Elektro-Engineer, der programmieren kann.
Ja, bei uns gibt es auch einige Quereinsteiger.
Es ist ein Unterschied, ob man mit Leuten im Stream redet oder ob man mit Leuten, wo
man real life nicht klarkommt, irgendwie klarkommen muss, weil man jetzt mit denen im Meeting
sitzt.
Ich komme mit den meisten Leuten klar, ohne Scheiß, Leute, ich bin da äußerst umgänglich.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die mich nerven, zum Beispiel, wenn Leute irgendwie so auf
super krassen Alfa-Mail machen irgendwo, die an der Position überhaupt nicht sind, jeder
kennt es, ist irgendein Meeting, du hast irgendeinen Typ da sitzen, der allen erzählen will, wo
es lang geht, obwohl das überhaupt nicht sein Job ist an der Stelle.
Das geht mir mega auf den Keks, Alter.
Die dann irgendwie so, ja, weiß nicht, so.
So möchte gern Giga-Chat auftreten.
Gibt es P-... gibt es immer noch, ja?
Den gibt es immer noch, da isser.
Aber ich hab den Zugang nicht mehr, ich hab den Zugang verloren zu LinkedIn und das,
obwohl ich dort Cloud-Native-Agile-GitOps-Solution-Chief-Engineer-Officer bin, man.
Hast du Erfahrungen mit CCNA?
Ja, ich hab mal eine CCNA gemacht in meiner Ausbildung.
Kein Plan mehr von.
Also, wenn du eine Stelle gefunden hast, die nahezu eins zu eins auf dich zutrifft, dann
bewirb dich da.
Ob es manche Punkte gibt, die nicht zutreffen, das ist egal.
Die freuen sich schon, wenn sie einen Bewerber finden, der auch nur 70-80% hat.
Und das andere kriegst du easy.
Wenn du Ahnung hast von irgendwas in dieser Richtung, arbeitest du dich da easy ein.
Ich würd mich da auf jeden Fall drauf bewerben, wenn dir das gefällt.
Keine Ahnung, ich bin nicht bei LinkedIn und Sing.
Ich kann dir sagen, was mein Kollege bekommt, der bekommt irgendwie, was hat er jetzt, 30
Stück in der Woche oder so, oder was am Tag?
Nee, ich glaub, in der Woche hat er letzte Woche irgendwie 30 Stück gekriegt.
Das ist halt vieles unbrauchbare Kram dabei.
Ja, 30 Stück, ich glaub, es war die Woche.
Blutscht, die suchen alle wie verrückt und sind auch oftmals die gleichen.
So, ich weiß nicht, ob du mich meinst, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich dazu was gesagt hab.
Ich verstehe, warum externe 5-10 mal so viel kosten.
Also die verdienen ja auch gar nicht 5-10 mal so viel.
Warum externe 5-10 mal so viel kosten ist ja, der Typ an sich ist nicht billig, der verdient
auch sicherlich mehr, aber da sind dann noch 2-3 Vermittler dazwischen.
Das kostet Geld und außerdem mussten sie sich das bezahlen lassen, dass sie von heute
auf morgen nicht mehr da sein können.
Ja doch, mir ist vollkommen klar, warum externe Leute mehr verdienen.
Warum man allerdings den Anteil der Externen oftmals so hoch schraubt, anstatt zu gucken,
dass die eigenen Leute da bleiben, das erleuchtet mir bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber weniger
ein.
Man könnte ja durchaus dafür sorgen, dass die eigenen Leute da bleiben, wenn man da
manche Sachen machen würde, die sauer aufstoßen.
Das ist tatsächlich schwierig, bekannter um 3 Ecken Leute, wirklich bekannter, also
der Mann von der Tochter von einer Freundin von meiner Mutter, also Leute das ist wirklich
weird champ Bekanntschaft um 50 Ecken, der macht Granomenschulung zum fachinformatischer
Anwendungsentwicklung und der hat mich gefragt, ob ich mal bei uns anfragen könnte, ob er
dort sein Praktikum machen kann, weil die müssen wohl irgendwie neun Monate Praktikum
machen, dass sie ihre Abschlussprüfung schreiben dürfen, irgendwie sowas.
Habe ich gefragt bei unserem Ausbildungschef oder Ausbildungsabteilung da, die das halt
machen und die haben ewig gebraucht und im Endeffekt haben sie abgesagt und ich habe
halt einfach die Vermutung sie haben nicht abgesagt, weil es wirklich keine Möglichkeiten
gibt, sondern weil sie schlicht und ergreifend keinen Bock hatten sich darum zu kümmern.
Weil ich war dann hartnäckig und habe mehrfach noch nachgefragt, auch über meinen Chef und
dann wurde mir einfach abgesagt, ne geht nicht, ich glaube die hatten schlicht und ergreifend
keinen Bock und da muss man sich nicht wundern, wenn man nicht ausbilden will beziehungsweise
Leute mehr oder weniger die fast schon fertig sind auf dem Servieteller präsentiert bekommt
und die nicht will, da muss man sich halt nicht wundern, wenn man auch irgendwo keine
Leute mehr hat irgendwann.
Richtig, genau, das kannst du mit externen Leuten so machen.
Blöd ist es halt natürlich nur, wenn man externe Leute hat, die wichtige Sachen umsetzen,
die dann rausschmeißt und feststellt, Mist, wir haben ja niemand, der sich mit dem Kram
ja auskennt.
Weil mit dem Rausschmiss des Externs quasi die Ahnung über diesen Service auch komplett
mit rausgeschmissen wurde.
Das ist dann aber ein Management Fail.
Ja ganz klar, naja, Leute, viereinhalb Stunden, guck mal, 4.20 haben wir jetzt, ich bin jetzt
4 Stunden 20 Minuten am Stream, ich gehe jetzt off, was futtern, wir haben ganz schön lange
geschwätzt jetzt noch, wir haben über eineinhalb Stunden glaube ich einfach jetzt nur über
das, über IT und Job und sonst was geredet, aber musste anscheinend auch mal sein.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream Leute, machts gut bis denn, ich geh jetzt was essen, ich
hab übelst Hunger, machts gut bis denn, see you.